BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE
WE'RE HERE FOR A FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH HEARING THIS IS
THE THIRD HEARING- IN A ROW I
THINK IT'S VERY- WHERE WE WILL
BE TAKING NO ACTION ON ANY OF
THE ITEMS BUT WE WILL HAVE A
NUMBER OF. INDICATIONS UNDER-
ITEMS TO BE HEARD. FIVE BEFORE
WE BEGIN AS WITH EVERY MEETING
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THE HEARING
TODAY TO HELP ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF EVERYONE WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION.
TODAY AS YOU KNOW WE'RE HAVING-
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE STATE CAPITAL
WERE IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN.
IN ORDER TO KEEP SIX FEET OF
SPACING UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL A-
MAKE SOME OF THESE COMMENTS
AGAIN WENT PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS AT THE END OF OUR AGENDA.
BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. PLEASE RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. WHILE
YOU'RE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE WHEN YOU'RE AT THE
MICROPHONE AND PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. EACH OF YOU WELL- YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE PUBLIC COMMENT IS DOWN
OR YOU CAN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT
BUT AGAIN OBSERVING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING ADULT TIME. AND
PARTICULARLY UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING OUR RULE HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WHICH LIMITS
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME THAT HASN'T SLOWED ME DOWN
BY MUCH. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA AND THE L. A. O. R.
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY AGAIN NOT VOTING AND
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE WILL ACCEPT
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN YOU'RE
WATCHING IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THAT'S TOLL FREE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957. WE HAVE A PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE DATA THAT YOU WANT
TO PUNCH AND THAT ONCE YOU GET
THROUGH ON THAT NUMBER THAT'S.
1-315-437-1315 FOUR THREE SEVEN
AND IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS. YOU'RE WELCOME TO
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099
THAT'S. 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL BE THERE TO
ASSIST YOU. I THOUGHT WE WILL.
BEGIN THE HEARING WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF NON PRESENTATION
ITEMS AND I REMIND EVERYONE
THAT. THE NON PRESENTATION
CALENDAR IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE
CALL WHEN WE'RE VOTING- THE
VOTE O THE CALENDAR BUT SINCE
THERE'S NO VOTING TAKING PLACE.
THESE ARE SIMPLY ITEMS THAT ARE
NOT BEING PRESENTED- ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS ON THE- LAUNDRIES
IN TASTING COUNTER MISTER
SMITH. YES MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU YOU'RE ACTUALLY ON ITEM
THREE WOULD JUST I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. ITEM AGREE ON
WELL THREE FIVE THREE OKAY WHO
HAD BEFORE COME FORWARD AND
MAYBE WE CAN GET HIM ADDRESSED.
BCP IN THE CASE OF THE
REGISTRATION FEES WILL NEED TO
BE INCREASED. BUT HOW MUCH ARE
THEY PROPOSING TO BE INCREASED.
SO COULD I JUST- I APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING YOU- SINCE
THESE ARE ON THE NON
PRESENTATION CALENDAR THERE MAY
NOT BE ANYBODY. OFF FROM DPR-
OR DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES AND
RECYCLE RESOURCES RECYCLING AND
RECOVERY- WHO ARE LISTENING TO
THE HEARING- OR CERTAINLY WHO
ARE HERE TO MAKE PRESENTATIONS
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA WANT TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE MADE
AWARE OF YOUR COMMENTS AND
MAYBE GET AN ANSWER RESPONSE
FACTOR. BECAUSE IT WILL BE A IT
WILL BE HARDER TO DISCUSS IN
THE FUTURE ITEM IT'LL COME UP
FOR A VOTE. WOULD LIKE SOME
ANSWERS MIGHT CHANGE WHICH WAY
ABOUT AND- YOU KNOW BY YOUR
ASKING THE QUESTIONS HERE ON
THE DYESS- I CERTAINLY WILL
BACK YOU UP MAKING SURE THAT
YOU GET ANSWERS TO YOUR
QUESTION PERFECT. QUESTIONS AND
ENOUGH. OF AND HOW MUCH
DESERVED OF. HOW VISITED OF
BILLY CAPITA WILL RE. THE
NUMBERS. BY IT IF INCREASE FEES
HAVE A WILL TO GO. AND WHAT OF
SORT OF ACCOUNT. MEASURES HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE TO ENSURE
EFFICIENCY. GIVEN THAT THEY
ALMOST QUADRUPLING THE COST OF
THE PROGRAM. THAT FOR NUMBER
THREE. THE NUMBER FIVE IT'S
PRETTY MUCH OF TIMING BECAUSE
IT STARTED IN- OR DID AGO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN SUPPOSED TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BY TWENTY.
TWENTY TWO THE WITH THE COVERT
SITUATION I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
BACKLOG CAN HELP US PUSH THIS
TIMELINE BACK A LITTLE BIT.
HOME WHAT DO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED IN ORDER TO BE ACHIEVED
SUCCESS. MMHM GO WITH THE HAVE
WE ACHIEVED THE TWENTY TWENTY
GOLF BY THE VERSION OF THE 50%
MMHM IN WHAT IS THE CURRENT
RATED DIVERSION. CAL RECTAL CAL
RECYCLE IS ISSUED. ISSUES WITH
REGULATIONS TAKING LONGER THAN
EXPECTED TO REQUIREMENT
ENFORCEMENT IS SIGNIFICANT.
WIDE WHY WOULD WE GIVE THEM
MORE FLEXIBLE TIME FOR THE
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS THE
SLOWDOWN IN THE TIMING OF TALK
ABOUT EARLIER- THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION OF DELAYING THE
INFLAMMATION AND PLAN THAT THEY
HAVE IMPLEMENTATION FOR ONE
YEAR. BECAUSE OF COVERED
NINETEEN. AND IT SEEMS THAT WE
SHOULD WANT TO SET UP THE VOTE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL TO ACHIEVING THIS
GOAL. FOR PRETTY MUCH OF IF
IT'S TAKING LONGER TO IMPLEMENT
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME IT HAS BEEN
A YEAR EIGHTEEN MONTHS. AND
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE FOR THOSE
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
YOU'RE WELCOME- SO WE'LL MOVE
ON NOW TO ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
OUR FIRST ISSUE. IS WITH THAT
CAL P. A. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SMALL GRANT PROGRAM. IT
IS THAT YOUR BILL WITHOUT I AM
THE SECRETARY- CAN I ASK YOU TO
HOLD FOR ONE SECOND WE'RE GOING
ON A VERY DISTRACTING ECHO HERE
IN THE- IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THANK GOOD MORNING AGAIN
SECRETARY. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BLOOM HOW ARE YOU
TODAY- I'M DOING OKAY AND I
DON'T MIND HEARING YOU THREE
TIMES. EVERY TIME YOU SPEAK BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY AND CORRECT
FOR THAT. TO HAVE SOMEBODY. WHO
CAN WORK ON THAT. THE KEEP
TESTING ONE TWO. I JUST STUCK
WITH ALL CLOSE OUR EYES AND
IMAGINE THAT WE'RE IN A
BEAUTIFUL VALLEY AND HEAR
VOICES ECHOING FROM ONE SIDE OF
THE VALLEY TO THE OTHER LIKE A
GUIDED MEDITATION RICHARD
UNLIKELY. ONE IT'S SOMETHING IN
THE SUBJECT THEY FAVOR
EVERYTHING ELSE IS CONNECTED
PROPERLY I'M NOT SURE OKAY
SOMETHING ITSELF OKAY SO WE'VE
LOCATED THE PROBLEM IS IN THE
ROOM BUT WE HAVEN'T SOLVED IT.
I EIGHTY PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY I'M
AND JUST ABOUT IT WILL GET BACK
IN. THE TH IT'S GOING TO BE
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DECIPHER
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. AND IN THE
IN SPITE OF YOUR CHARACTERISTIC
CLARITY. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU WANT TO GIVE THIS A
TRY I LIVE IN. YEAH IT'S NOT
JUST ME. IS THAT BETTER NO I
DON'T THINK IT'S ON YOUR AND
SECRETARY. HAVE WE CAN TURN
MAYBE TURN ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
OFFER AT. I WAS NEVER THE AV
GUY AT THE SCHOOL PLACE SO I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HELP. AT
THE TURN OFF THE MICROPHONES
WITHOUT HIM. IS EVERYBODY'S
MICROPHONE OFF. OKAY. RIGHT FOR
TURN MINA. YEAH THEY SENT TO
MYSELF WILL HELP. TESTING. ONE
TWO THREE. TESTING ONE TWO
THREE. WITH A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
TRY ONE MORE TIME. THREE ALL
THE OKAY IT WAS MY RED BUTTON.
SOMEBODY JUST ARRIVED WHO WHO
KNEW THAT THAT WAS THE
PROFLIGATE. OKAY MY MICROPHONE
IS HOT THOUGH SO AND THE YELLOW
BUTTON IS UP THE WHITE BUTTON
IS DOWN THE RED BUTTON IS DOWN.
WE'RE GOOD TO GO SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD WELCOME. A. J. AB
PATIENTS I'M SO AGAIN MY NAME
IS GERRY BLUMENFELD I'M THE
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND I'M EXTREMELY PROUD- OF ALL
THE WORK BEING DONE BY THE
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
THAT COUNTY CALLIE PA. AND
THROUGH TODAY'S HEARING- AND
AGENDA ITEMS THAT YOU'LL PAY
BEFORE YOU OUR GOAL IS TO
ENDEAVOR TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF SOME OF OUR-
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY THE ONES
I'M THAT AT A FUTURE MEETING
WILL BE FEEL BUDGET DECISIONS.
I'M LATER YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH'S
QUESTION I'M YOU GONNA HEAR
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL ON ISSUES
FROM EXIDE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
REALLY IMPORTANT PARTNERSHIP
WITH ALL OF YOU ON GOVERNANCE
AND FISCAL REFORM- WE LEAD FROM
OUR EXPERIENCE EXCITED THAT AND
UNDER RESOURCE DEPARTMENT. CAN
LEAD TO VERY VERY SERIOUS
IMPACTS WHOLE COMMUNITY I'M FOR
ENFORCEMENT AND- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. EVENTS LIKE EXCITED NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN- REALLY GOOD NEWS
THE DGSE IS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVED ITS STEWARDSHIP OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES BY CONDUCTING
A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF ITS
PROGRAMS AND MAKING SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE QUALITY AND
TIMELINESS OF IT SERVICES. YOU
ALSO HERE I THINK THIS IS A
QUESTION THAT ASSEMBLY MEANT
SMITH RAISED ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AND THE QUEST TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN MOVE. TO
A PLACE OF SAFEST ATTAINABLE
PEST MANAGEMENT- TO THE
CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES THAT SUPPORT NON
CONVENTIONAL PEST MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES FOR SPECIALTY
CROPS. RESET EXOTIC PESTS THAT
ARE LIKELY TO ARRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA PROACTIVELY IDENTIFY-
MITIGATION STRATEGIES AND
PROVIDE OUTREACH OF VIOLET
BIOLOGICALLY INTEGRATED CLOUD
BASED FARMING SYSTEMS THAT
REDUCE PESTICIDE USE YOU'LL
ALSO HEAR I'M FROM CARRY CYCLE.
THAT CAN HOPEFULLY ON TO SOME
OF YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE.
VISION AND EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
NINE AND- I CAN YOU KNOW I
MEMBER THAT YES WE DID. THE
STATE'S 50% GO I WAS TRYING TO
ME THE STATE SEVEN FIVE. THE GO.
AND YOU KNOW HE FROM THE
DIRECTIVE CAL RECYCLING THAT.
THE ISSUE BEFORE US TODAY AT
EIGHT AM IS THE E. J. SCHOOL
GROUNDS PROGRAM. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS TO HAVE THAT
REALLY SPECIAL PLACE IN MY
HEART I'M IT'S AN INCREDIBLY.
EFFECTIVE DROP PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS A WIDE VARIETY OF
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF OUR
TOUGHEST ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES. IT SINGULARLY
FOCUSED ON FUNDING PROJECTS
MAKING THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE.
FOR A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND AT THE
MONTREUX COBIT NINETEEN FOR
THIS PROGRAM ASSEMBLY INCREASED
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE PROGRAM
APPLICANTS REQUESTED FULL
MILLION. IN GRANT FUND THING
WITH ANY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
IN FUNDS TO DISTRIBUTE. THE
CROWD SO WHAT IT DID LAST YEAR
FUNDED PROJECTS RANGING FROM
IMPLEMENTING YOU CHEMICAL
EXPOSURE AND CUT WITH NINETEEN
SAFETY MEASURES AND NAIL SALON
WORKERS TO ENGAGING HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ACROSS CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. AND CLIMATE ACTION
PLANNING REFUNDED GROUPS IN THE
SAMIC. PLAN ELSEWHERE TO
SUPPORT FORMERLY. INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WHICH- AND IT. DIDN'T
BUT THEN IT COMMUNITY IT'S
INTEREST WE FIND CUTTING RITA
EXAMINING BATH AND MENTAL
HEALTH I'M TAKING MY MOTHERS
AND FAMILIES IN FRESNO AND AT
THE TIME WHEN OUT FRONT LINE
WORKERS HAVE SHOWN HOW CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL AND VULNERABLE THEY
CAN OFTEN BE WE OFTEN FUNDED
INDIGENOUS LED ORGANIZATIONS TO
SHOW THAT HEALTH AND OTHER
SAFETY INFORMATION IS
DISSEMINATED IN NON ENGLISH
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE SPEAKING TO
A DEGREE FOR FIELD WORKERS THAT
IS THE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
WHAT THE PROGRAM TO LIVE WITH
EACH YEAR. PRIVATE FUNDING
SOURCES OF THIS PROGRAM HAVE
GENERALLY BEEN PENALTY FUNDS
INCLUDING WAY FOR THE DISCHARGE
APPLICATION CONTROL FUNDS IN
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECT TOSCA FUNDS AND
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM FUNDING SOURCES OF ALL
SAYS TAMAL LIMITED EXTENT
SUPPORTED THE PROGRAM IDEALLY
WE WANT TO VARIETY OF PENALTY
OR GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROGRAM AGAIN IN THE LIGHT OF
CURRENT DEMANDS ON THE
APPLICATION CONTROL AND WASTE
WATER DISCHARGE FUNDS TO FILL
BUDGET SHORTFALL. THOSE
ACCOUNTS SIMPLY WOULD NOT
FEASIBLE AT THIS BUDGET CYCLE
SAID THE REQUEST THIS YEAR'S
TOSCA FOR ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS APPROPRIATION
AND IT- UNTIL ABLE TO SECURE AN
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCE
CONTINUOUS FUNDING SOURCE THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE A VIABLE
OPTION- WE HOPE TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO GROW THIS PROGRAM AND
EVENTUALLY- FIND SOURCES OF THE
SLIGHTLY MORE STABLE SAYS THAT-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- CAN
TALK MORE ABOUT THIS ITEM BUT
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
AND I JUST WANT TO CLOSE AND
THANKING- ALL OF YOU FEEL
PARTNERSHIP THIS REALLY. IS A
PARTNERSHIP IN GOOD GOVERNANCE
ESPECIALLY LATE AT CAL POLY PA
THIS YEAR WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE HOW DO WE GET THE
T. S. A. TOOK PLACE THAT CAN
REALLY BE ON IT SEE HOW DO WE
RE THINK SOME OF THE FEES AND
STRUCTURES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION SO THAT WE.
CAN REDUCE SOCIETY IT'S REALLY
I WOULD GOT WHACKED WE WORK
COLLABORATIVE WITH USE OF I
WANT TO YOU AND IT. FOR THAT
WELL CAN FEEL PARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE- DO WE HAVE A-
FROM THE L. A. O. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH THE
PROPOSED ACTIVITIES I THINK THE
MAIN ISSUE HERE IS HOW RELATED
TO THE FUNDING SOURCE- AS WITH
MENTIONS THE PROPOSED BAN
SOURCES TOSCO ACCOUNT WE DO
THINK. ABOUT THAT IS AN
ALLOWABLE FUND SOURCE AND THERE
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT FUNDS IF
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED GSE REFORM
PROPOSAL- HOWEVER WE DO THINK
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
AN ALTERNATIVE APPROACH AS A
SECRETARY. MENTIONED IN THE
PAST- A MIX OF DIFFERENT
SPECIAL FUNDS HAVE BEEN USED
OPPORTUNITIES AND OTHER SOURCES
TO FIND THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES. ARE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD EXPLORE THAT-
THIS TIME AROUND AS WELL AND
ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
YOUR STAFF TO KIND OF IDENTIFY.
THE OPTIONS AND ALTERNATIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BINANCE
ZERO EIGHT APARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AT THIS TIME THAT HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT- LET ME ASK A QUESTION
AND- THE- REBALANCING OF THIS
FUND IS DEPENDENT ON THE HAVE A
REFORM PLAN TO REQUIRES A TWO
THIRDS VOTE WHICH IS A PRETTY.
A STEEP CLIMB IN THE BEST OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. BOB IS THERE A-
CONTINGENCY PLANS. IF THE FEE
REFORM PROPOSAL DOESN'T COME TO
FRUITION. JOINING CHAIR AT NJ
MARCH WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
WE'RE VERY CONFIDENT IN OUR
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR WE HAVE BEEN
A LOT OF TIME LAST YEAR WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
WHAT LEARNED- THE LOOKING
FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR AND- AND GETTING
REFORM PASSED. WELL OKAY- AND-
NOT REALLY IN A PLACE TO SHARE
YOUR ENTHUSIASM AND I THINK
THAT'S BASED ON THE HISTORY
LEADING UP TO THIS- UP TO THIS
POINT IN TERMS OF- THOUGH THE
WAY THIS FUND WHICH I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH SECRETARY BLUMENTHAL
IS A- EXCELLENT FUND. AND USE
FOR MANY MANY IMPORTANT
PURPOSES AND IT'S VERY
EFFICIENTLY- HUH UTILIZED BUT-
EITHER WAY WE HAVE- PROBE- HAS
DONE THE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM. I THINK EVERYBODY
AGREES AS SUCH IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AND IT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT TO CHALLENGING TOGETHER
TO. HOW TO GET THE FEW REFORM
THE PROPOSAL PASSED BUT- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER- QUESTIONS. ON
THIS ITEM. CORRECT- THEN THE-
OUR RECOMMENDATION HARRIS- THAT
WE OF FUNDERS REQUEST
EXCLUSIVELY WITH A DEBT THAT
FUNDING REQUEST- WITH TOSCA
FUNDS IS BECAUSE INAPPROPRIATE.
AND THAT- THERE BE A MORE
APPROPRIATE COMBINATION OF FUND
SOURCES- OR JUST USE THE
GENERAL FUND AND I FRANKLY HAVE
TO AGREE WITH THAT- I THINK
THAT WOULD BE THE MOST DIRECT
WAY. OF OF FUNDING THIS RATHER
THAN TAKING IT FROM TAKING THE
MONEY FROM FUNDS THAT ARE CAN
APPROPRIATE- SO THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
WERE BACK FOR ANOTHER YEAR OF-
REPORTING ON THE- EXIDE. COST
RECOVERY IN RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP
THAT- HAS AFFECTED TO A
NEIGHBORHOOD AND- LOS ANGELES-
LIKE CUT AND NOTHING ELSE IN
THIS IN THE STATE IF THE
CONTAMINATION ISSUE THAT HAS
LASTED NOW FOR A- OF MANY
YEARS. AND WAS GLAD TO HEAR
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD A
SUGGESTED TO OTHER ORGANISMS
CHANGES AT THE TSC THAT WILL
HELP. MAKE THIS CLEAN UP MORE
EFFICIENT AND- MAKE IT HAPPEN
MORE RAPIDLY FOR THE RESIDENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN- I WANT TO SAY
PATIENTLY WAITING BUT- THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE IMPATIENT
TONIGHT AND THEY ARE IMPATIENT.
AND THEN WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
SEE ACTION SO OF- IS SET WILL
BE RECEIVING A REPORT FROM. THE
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS WITH US. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BLEW UP MY
NAME IS GREG COHEN THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CLEAN UP
PROGRAM. I'LL BE TALKING TO YOU
THIS MORNING SUMMARIZING THE
ACTUATORS INITIAL CLEAN UP
BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE
COST TO COVER. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. THE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS REQUESTING
THIRTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND LOAN FROM
TOSCA BUT TO CLEAN UP THREE TWO
HUNDRED PROPERTIES THIS
INCLUDES TWENTY THREE POINT
NINE MILLION FOR CLEAN UP
CONTRACTS AND ROUGHLY SEVEN
POINT FIVE IN FOR SUPPORT THAT
IS DIRECTLY NECESSARY FOR THE
SUCCESS OF THOSE CLEAN- THE
MONEY INVESTED IN CLEANING UP
PROPERTIES AROUND EXCITE IS
EXTREMELY. IS EXTREMELY
EFFICIENTLY USE MORE THAN 90%
OF THE CLEAN UP FUNDS GO TO
PLAY PAY FOR CLEANUP ACTIVITIES.
OKAY WE CLEANED UP MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED EAST WHICH
IS A RATE THAT HAS- CLEANING UP
MORE PROPERTIES MORE QUICKLY
THAN ANY OTHER RESIDENTIAL THAT
BASED. CLEAN UP IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
COULD WORK- BY PROTECTING
PEOPLE FROM LED. IN THEIR
YARDS- UNDER THE BUDGET CHANGE-
A REQUEST- WE ANTICIPATE BEING
AROUND TWENTY HUNDRED
PROPERTIES BY THE END OF THE
YEAR AND- COMPLETING THE TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED CLEANUPS ARE BY
FAR THE TWENTY TWENTY TO. I
WILL NOW WE WANT TO THE
CATEGORY B. C. P. JUST
SUMMARIZE IT QUICKLY AT THAT
REQUEST. AND DINNER IS
REQUESTING SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOURTEEN
MILLION OTHER COMES FROM THE
GENERAL FUND BY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION OF IT COMES FROM THE
LEAD ACID BATTERY CLEANUP FUND-
WITH AN ANNUAL- TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION THEREAFTER FROM LUBBOCK
TO CONTINUE COST RECOVERY
EFFORTS. FOR THIS REQUEST
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION WILL
COME FROM- WILL GO TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR
LEGAL SUPPORT COST RECOVERY
EFFORTS. A ONE POINT ONE
MILLION WILL GO TO OUTSIDE
COUNSEL TO CONTINUE THEIR VERY
STRONG- ACTIONS IN NOT PURSUING
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES EXIDE. TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION WILL GO TO
FUND A SIX LEGAL POSITIONS
WITHIN AGENCIES OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL- WE'RE GOING TO USE ALL
THOSE FUNDS TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
COSTA CURRENT CLEANING UP
CONTAMINATION AROUND THE FORMER
ECCENTRICITY- BUT ALSO AT OTHER
LEAD ACID BATTERY FACILITIES
UNDER THE LEAD ACID BATTERY
INVESTIGATION CLEANUP PROGRAM.
THANK YOU TNCS- OF COURSE COST
RECOVERY IS A VERY COMPLEX
UNDERTAKING ESPECIALLY AND
URBAN ENVIRONMENTS. BUT WE ARE
IN COURT TODAY. HOLDING
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE-
FOR THE EXCITED FOR THE
CONTAMINATION OF THE FORMER
EXCITED DISABILITY AND-
WHELCHEL A LONG WAY TO GO
BEFORE WORK THE END OF THIS
PROCESS WE WANT UNDER THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE
THOSE GOOD ACTORS CAN'T
CONTINUE THAT COULD WORK.
SECOND QUARTER REPORT. YES ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A
REPORT FROM- OR COMMENTS FROM
ALEJO. I'M GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRANK MENDEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
OF THOSE RINGS NO CONCERNS FOR
OFFICE WITH THE LET'S IN THE
STATE'S BEST INTERESTS TO FULLY
FUND- DETAILS C. N. DOJ AND ANY
COST RECOVERY EFFORTS REGARDING
I'M EXCITED. AND THEN WITH THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP REQUEST-
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CLAIM THAT THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED- PROPERTIES THAT IT
INTENDED FROM THE BEGINNING SO
NO CONCERNS FROM OUR OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR A FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING AND YOUR MARK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NOTHING
TO ADD AT THIS TIME THE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I'M- I'M NOT SURE IF
OF MR COPAS. BEST SITUATED TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION OR FINANCE
BUT- I DID I HEAR CORRECTLY
THAT- THE- THIRTY TWO HUNDREDS
OF PROPERTIES ARE EXPECTED TO
BE- QUICKEN THE CLEANING IS
EXPECTED TO BE COMPLETE BY
TWENTY TWENTY TO. THAT'S
CORRECT. AND DOES THAT INCLUDE
THE PARKWAYS AND- ALL OF THE
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED.
THAT ONLY INCLUDES THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP PARKWAYS-
ARE SEPARATE- ESSENTIALLY
SEPARATE PROGRAM FROM THE CLEAN
UP THE RESIDENTIAL AREAS. OKAY
WEEK ALLOCATED TO I THINK IT
WAS SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TWO OR THREE YEARS
AGO- FOR CLEANUP OF THOSE
PROPERTIES SO. WHY IS IT SOUNDS
LIKE THAT'S LAGGING BEHIND
WHITES THAT. WE HAVE A
SUFFICIENT FUNDS CURRENTLY. TO
MOVE FORWARD AND ACTUALLY DO
THE ANALYSIS NEEDED TO DRIVE-
WHAT THE CLEANUPS DATA WOULD BE
THAT APPLIES TO THOSE OF
PARKWAYS BUT AT THIS POINT WE
DO NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS.
TO PAY FOR THE ACTUAL CLEANUP
OF THE PARK PLACE. DO YOU HAVE
AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT THAT COST
IS GOING TO BE. WITH THE FOR
THE REST OF THIS. YEAH THE
ATTACHMENTS GOING TO DEPEND
UPON THE CLEANUP STANDARDS THAT
WE APPLY TO THOSE PARKWAYS
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. NOW OF FINALIZING A
RISK ASSESSMENT. THAT WILL USE
TO DERIVE A CLEANUP STANDARDS.
VIAV SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ADDED TO YOUR
BUDGET- IN THAT. FISCAL YEAR-
SEVERAL YEARS AGO- AFTER
RESIDENTS CAME TO US AND
COMPLAINED THAT THE PARKWAYS
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM. AND WE MADE A
SPECIAL EFFORT TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THAT THAT WORK
COULD MOVE FORWARD- AND-
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL WHEN YOU COMMENT MAKE A
PRESENTATION TO THIS COMMITTEE
THAT YOU UPDATE US ON THOSE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE
SPECIFICALLY MADE A PRIORITY
FOR YOU AND PROVIDED THE
FUNDING THAT WAS NECESSARY TO
MOVE FORWARD. ABSOLUTELY
CHAIRMAN WE- WE ARE STILL USING
ALL THE MONEY THAT WE HAD AND
CONVERT I'M UP TO THE- YOU KNOW
FOR THE INITIAL INVESTIGATION
AND RISK ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
DUE TO- JUST GO CONSTRAINTS
THAT OCCURRED- WHEN THE
PANDEMIC CARE. FUNDS THAT WERE
NOT ENCUMBERED THE FUNDS THAT
WE HADN'T PUT IN THE CONTRACT-
WERE WITHDRAWN FROM- ARTILLERY
TO USE THEM. ABOUT WE INTEND TO
USE ALL THE MONEY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW TO DO ALL
THE WORK THAT WE CAN- WITHIN
THOSE RESOURCES WELL I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT-
THAT- THINGS HAVE BEEN HELD UP
TO THE PANDEMIC- AND SO WHAT I
WOULD REQUEST IS WHEN. YOU COME
BACK AFTER THE MAY REVISED AND-
AND WE FEEL GAP THAT WE HAVE A
FULL REPORT ON. THE STATUS OF
THE- OF THE PARKWAY PROJECT- IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THE OTHER
ITEMS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO. A.
A COMPLETING THIS
DECONTAMINATION. I THANK YOU.
SO SHOULD WE BE EXPECTING A IN
THIS THE SCHOOL YEAR- A OF
PROPOSAL ASKING FOR RESOURCES
TO COVER REMAINING PROPERTIES
AND- IF NOT THIS YEAR THEN WHEN
DO YOU ANTICIPATE MAKING THAT
REQUEST. TRY THAT DIFFICULTY
GETTING UP WITH MUTE- WE'RE
WE'RE FOCUSED LIKE A LASER ON
COMPLETING THE TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED CLEAN UP PROPERTIES-
THIS YEAR. AND SHOULD BE-
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS BE
PROVIDED WE WILL BE EQUALLY AS
FOCUSED ON COMPLETING THE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED A CLEAN UPS
I NEXT YEAR. ON THE CHURCH I
KIND OF WORK THAT GOES INTO
THAT AND- THE BUDGET I THINK
THAT THEY'RE NOT IN THE BUDGET.
REQUEST REFLECTS THAT. AND I'M
ASSUMING- AS A STAFF REPORT TO-
INDICATES THAT THE TWENTY SIX
POINT TWO MILLION IN FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CLOSURE IS NOT
GONNA BE ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH THE CLOSURE- SO.
WHEN WOULD WE ANTICIPATE A
REQUEST FOR THAT. SO DTS IS
WORKING RIGHT NOW WITH- USEPA
WHO'S THE LEAD REGULATORY
AGENCIES OVERSEEING THE- FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL TRUST'S WORK
UNDER THE BANKRUPTCY ORDER- WE
ARE WORKING WITH YOUR CPA TO
MAKE CERTAIN THE TRUST IS
PRIORITIZE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
NECESSARY TO- TECH PUBLIC
HEALTH- INCOMPLETE NEEDED
ACTIONS USING AVAILABLE FUNDS.
WE AND HE WAS HE CARE
MONITORING THE TRUST
EXPENDITURES. AND WHEN WE
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL FUNDS- AS
AS AS THEY COME UP ON ANY
PROJECT THAT AS NEEDED WE WILL
YOU KNOW WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION. I THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MISTER SMITH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- HOW MUCH IS TOTALLY BEEN
RECOVERED FROM EXCITED SO FAR.
THE THE DEPARTMENT JUST FILED
THE COST RECOVERY. ACTION
AGAINST RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OPERATION
OF THE FACILITY SO THAT ACTION
IS BEING UNDERTAKEN RIGHT NOW.
SO WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE OF
TAXPAYERS OF MY MATHIS-
ANYWHERE CLOSE INFILL SPENT
CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. I'M JUST
WONDERING HOW MUCH OF WE GOT
BACK OUT OF THAT MONEY THAT WE
SPENT FOR THE- CITIZENS IN THAT
AREA. IN IN JUST A THINKING AS
OF PASSED CONTRACTOR YOU HAD
THE FUNDING FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
SIDE OF IT. YOU HAVE THE
FUNDING FOR THE PARK WICKS SIDE
OF IT CAN'T WE DO BOTH PROJECTS
AT THE SAME TIME OR WHY ARE WE
WAITING TO DO THE PARKWAY. YEAH
WE ARE WORKING CONCURRENTLY ON
BOTH RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP AS
WELL AS THE PARK PLACE. OKAY
CLEAR FOR THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ORIGINALLY A PARKWAYS
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE- AND
IN THE PROJECT AND SO THEY HAD
TO BE THEY HAD TO BE ADDED IN
AND- TO LOSE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF. CATCH UP THAT'S TAKING
PLACE THERE. BUT- THAT WAS A
BIG ISSUE A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
BUT IF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS- AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE THREE. ALSO WITH
THE TSA OF GOVERNANCE AND
FISCAL REFORM PACKAGE IN
GENERAL FUND BACK FROM. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. RECITED TO BE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
TO REVISE UGS HE'S GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE AND IT'S FEES IN TO
START THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL. CALIFORNIANS
NEEDED DGSE THAT CAN PROTECT
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT FROM
TOXIC ARM. ENGAGE CALIFORNIA
NEED TO DGSE THAT FUNCTIONS
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HELP FISCAL
STABILITY. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THESE
CRITICAL NEEDS. THIS REFORM HAS
BEEN YEARS IN THE MAKING AND
IT'S BEEN A TURN OVER THE YEARS
FRUSTRATIONS HAVE PERSISTED
WITH THE GST HAS MADE STEADY
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR OPENNESS
OUR PRODUCTIVITY AND OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH THOSE WHO
RESEARCH. WE HAVE THE RIGHT
LEADERSHIP TEAM IN PLACE NOW.
AND WE'RE PREPARED FOR THE
CHANGES PUT FORTH IN THE
PROPOSAL. COBIT NINETEEN AND
OTHER CHALLENGES TOWARD OUR
CHANCE FOR COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
LAST YEAR. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
MISS THIS YEAR'S OPPORTUNITY SO
EVEN MORE PREPARED NOW. THE
PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO ANSWER
THREE QUESTIONS FIRST OF ALL
WHAT PROGRAM SHOULD DGSE BE
DELIVER. SECOND OF ALL WHAT
FEES. AND REVENUES SUPPORT
THOSE SERVICES WHILE THEY
DISSENTED DISINCENTIVE BUYS THE
USE OF MISMANAGEMENT OF
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES. ALSO
THIRDLY WHAT GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE BEST SUPPORTS THAT
THE BEST FOSTERS TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROVIDE
STRONGER COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
THIS YEAR'S PROPOSAL IS SIMILAR
TO LAST YEAR'S IT ESTABLISHES A
BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FORTY TO
SET FEES BASED ON APPROPRIATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE. AND LIKE
LAST YEAR THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
AN OMBUDSPERSON WHO REPORTS TO
THE BOARD. IT HAS BEEN IT HAS A
SIMPLIFIED IT UP TO BE UPDATED
FEES FOR BOTH OF THE GSES
ACCOUNTS WITH THE COMPUTERS.
COACH BUT THIS YEAR'S PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN REVISED TO REFLECT ALL
THAT WE LEARNED LAST YEAR
PARTICULARLY THROUGH OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE. WE
URGE. WE HEARD CALLS FOR
STRONGER ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES A NUMBER FOR. WE HEARD
CALLS TO HEED THE LESSONS WE
LEARNED IN THE WAKE OF THE
EXITE BANKRUPTCY. AND WE HEARD
THAT THE STATUS QUO SERVICE
LEVELS ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE TO DO
WHAT'S EXPECTED OF US. SO IN
RESPONSE TO THESE CONCERNS THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSAL HAS SOME
IMPORTANT CHANGES. THOSE
DETAILS WERE PROVIDED IN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE RELEASED
JUST YESTERDAY. THE LANGUAGE
UPDATES THE FEE STRUCTURES
WHICH HAVEN'T BEEN MODIFIED
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BUT
DOES SO WITH AN APPROACH THAT'S
MINDFUL OF THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND BEEN
HIT HARD BY THE PANDEMIC. THE
BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES BY
SETTING PERMITTING DECISION
TIMELINE TO BE REPORTED ON TO
THE BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY. IN A HAS STRONGER
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE PROVISIONS.
IMPORTANTLY THE PROPOSED FEE
INCREASES WOULD COVER NOT JUST
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BUT
INCREASE CERTAIN LEVELS OF
SERVICE. ADDITIONAL REVENUE
WOULD ALLOW US TO START
INVESTIGATING THE ESTIMATED
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTAMINATED SITES AROUND THE
STATE. WOULD ALLOW US TO DO
MORE INSPECTIONS AND TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST MORE
HAZARDOUS WASTE VIOLATORS IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND IT
WOULD FUND A MODERNIZED
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN
FOR THE STATE. HOW ARE
ESTIMATES FOR THE WE NEED THE
RESOURCES ARE BASED ON THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WE RELEASED
IN JANUARY. THAT WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS WAS UNDERTAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO LEGISLATIVE AND
STAKEHOLDER REQUESTS FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING OUR
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT. THE
FINDINGS OF THE WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS SHOW WHAT DGSE CAN
ACCOMPLISH WHEN WE WHEN GIVEN
THE RIGHT RESOURCES. IT
PROVIDES THE LONG REQUESTED
TRANSPARENCY INTO HOW WE'RE
USING OUR RESOURCES BASED ON A
SNAPSHOT AT A PARTICULAR POINT
IN TIME. MIND YOU IT DOES NOT
HAVE THE DETAIL REQUIRED FOR
SPECIFIC BUDGETARY REQUESTS NOR
IS IT A COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
OF RESOURCES NEEDED FOR EVERY
DGSE STATUTORY AUTHORITY. BUT
THE DEEP BUT THE ANALYSIS DOES
SHOW THE MISALIGNMENT BETWEEN
EACH YES HE'S RESPONSIBILITIES
AND ITS RESOURCES. THAT MEANS
WERE UNABLE TO FULFILL CURRENT
MANDATES FOR TAKE ON ANY NEW
ACTIVITIES. YOU KNOW THIS IS
DOCUMENTS EXAMPLES OF SERVICES
DGSE COULD DELIVER WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. WE'VE
ESTIMATED THE RESOURCES NEEDED
TO CLOSE GAPS FOR WHAT WE JUDGE
TO BE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES IN ORDER
TO ANSWER THAT FIRST QUESTION
OF THE REFORM WHAT SERVICES
SHOULD DGSE WEBER. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE ON MORE
ENFORCEMENT IN AREAS KNOWN TO
HAVE A HIGH RATE OF VIOLATION.
HAZARDOUS WASTE TRANSPORTATION
JEWELRY CONTAINING METAL HEAVY
METALS THAT SOLD TO CHILDREN.
WE MUST HAVE RESOURCES TO
MAINTAIN OUR FEDERAL DELEGATION
OF OUR REQUIRE AFFORD. WE LACK
RESOURCES NEEDED TO COMPLETE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL FOUR
STEPS OF THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS GREEN CHEMISTRY
REGULATION. AND WE'VE USED OUR
EXPERIENCE FROM THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTING THE
VIOLATIONS SCORING PROCEDURE TO
ESTIMATE WHAT'S NEEDED FOR BSP
MOVING FORWARD. THESE ESTIMATES
SUPPORT DECISIONS ABOUT THE
SECOND OF THE THREE QUESTIONS
RAISED EARLIER WHAT FEES AND
REVENUES ARE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE DESIRED SERVICE LEVELS. THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT DGSE IS HAS THE
BALL. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
PERFORMANCE DRIVEN CULTURE WE
NOW RETOOL ESTABLISH CLEAR
METRICS ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS SO
THAT WE CAN TRACK PROGRESS. THE
AVERAGE TIME NEEDED TO ISSUE A
PERMIT DECISION IS NOT TWO
POINT FIVE YEARS THAT'S DOWN
FROM FOUR POINT FIVE YEARS. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN WE ONLY
ISSUED ONE PERMIT DECISION. WE
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES TO REFER ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS BY 43% BOTH USEPA JAM
THE PARCHMENT OF DEFENSE HAVE
LAUDED ARE IMPROVEMENTS ON
MANAGING RECORD CLEAN UP SITES
AND MEETING ENVIRONMENTAL
INDICATOR TARGETS FOR THOSE
CLEAN UP. WE'RE DOING WELL WITH
WHAT WE HAVE AT BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH. THE IMPROVE THE DGSE
MUST BE COMPLEMENTED BY THE
RIGHT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND
THE RIGHT RESOURCES FOR FORMING
THE TNC CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER
WE KNOW THAT THE FACILITIES
THAT HANDLE TOXIC MATERIALS ARE
LOCATED IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WHICH ARE EXPERIENCING NOT ONLY.
EXCESS ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS
BUT HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY DURING THE
CALL THE PANDEMIC. THE
CONTAMINATED SITES THAT NEED TO
BE CLEANED UP ARE LOCATED IN
THE SAME COMMUNITY. IT'S URGENT
THAT WE BEGIN TO INVESTIGATE
AND CLEAN UP THE SITES AT THE
SAME TIME WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT EACH
YEAR SEES WORK CONTRIBUTES TO
AN EX AN EQUITABLE. AFFORDABLE
EQUITABLE EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. CREATING JOBS THROUGH
CLEANUPS PUTTING WE BACK INTO
FOR PRODUCTIVE USE AND CREATING
CLIMATE FRIENDLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE PROCESS. LIKE IT
OR NOT OUR LIFESTYLES REQUIRE
MANY TOXIC CHEMICALS UNTIL THAT
CHANGES WE MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HARMFUL
MATERIALS THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
MODERN LIFE. IT IS UP TO DATE
TSC TO PROTECT AGAINST THE PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE HARPER FROM
THOSE CHEMICALS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION WE ARE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
TODAY AND CERTAINLY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS. AS WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FRANCESCA NERI WHO
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAIL
ABOUT HER PURPLE. REGISTER.
GOOD MORNING CHAPLAIN MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY- AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS FOR
DTS HE'S PROGRAM SOME PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS. SERVICER
CALIFORNIA- AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN DEVELOPING
THE PROPOSALS FOR CHEER TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU TODAY AS DR
WILLIAMS INDICATED WE'VE HEARD
YOU. AND THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDE
INCLUDES PROVISIONS BASED ON
YOUR FEEDBACK. I'LL BE
SUMMARIZING THE REQUEST FOR A
THE GENERAL FUND BACK FILL THE
BOARD AND ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY.
ADDING TO OUR DIRECTOR WILLIAMS
COMMENTS ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- RELEASED YESTERDAY
RELATED TO FEES. SO WE ARE
REQUESTING TWENTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND BACK FILL FOR THE HAZARDS
WHICH CONTROLLER CANNOT- I ALSO
KNOWN AS H. W. CA IT'S NOT A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT FOR SIX OUT
OF THE LAST SEVEN YEARS AND- IT
HAS RELIED ON THE GENERAL FUND
BACK FILL IMPOSSIBLE YEARS
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN. AND AT GENERAL FUND
BACKFILL IS AGAIN NEEDED AND
I'M BUDGET YOUR- ADDITIONALLY
WORK. THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND BACK FILL FOR
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT- IT IS ALSO RELIED ON A
GENERAL FUND BACKED- BEGINNING
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY. AND IS
AGAIN NEEDED IN BUDGET YEAR.
MOVING ON TO THE ON BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY WE ARE
REQUESTING FIFTEEN POSITIONS
AND THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND- IN BUDGET YEAR TO
SUPPORT THAT BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AN
OMBUDSMAN- FUTURE- RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THIS
BOARD- WOULD BE PROVIDED
THROUGH THE FEE REFORM EFFORT
QUITE DETAILED IN THAT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ON SAFETY AND-
THIS YEAR'S PROPOSALS SIMILAR
TO LAST IN THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING TO ESTABLISH A FIVE
MEMBER BOARD. FULL TIME CARE
AND FOR PART TIME MEMBERS.
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITIES WILL BE
TO SET THE AND FEE RATES THE
SITE PERMIT APPEALS PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE GSES PERMIT AND
REMEDIATION DECISIONS. REVIEW
AND APPROVE THE DIRECTOR'S
ANNUAL PRIORITIES AND
PERFORMANCE METRICS. I WORK
WITH THE DIRECTOR TO ESTABLISH
A LONG TERM GOALS FOR DGSE
PROGRAMS. AND PROVIDING ANNUAL
PERFORMANCE REVIEW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. THE OMBUDSMAN WOULD
RECEIVE AND EVALUATE COMPLAINTS
AND SUGGESTIONS REGARDING ANY
ACTION PROGRAM OUR POLICY IN
THE DEPARTMENT. IN ADDITION TO
THE BOARD AN OMBUDSMAN
POSITIONS- THESE RESOURCES
WOULD SUPPORT- BOARD SUPPORT
INCLUDING AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND POSITION
SCIENTISTS ENGINEERS ANALYST
AND ATTORNEY POSITIONS. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
DOCTOR REALLY WAS REFERRED TO
PROVIDE THE STATUTORY LANG-
CHANGES NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
DGSE WITH LONG TERM FISCAL
STABILITY IN ADDITION TO THE
PROVISION SHE'S ALREADY-
PROVIDED TO YOUR DISCUSS WITH
YOU I'M IT WOULD- SO THE RATES
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR H. WCN TOSCA TO
COVER THE GENERAL FUND BACK
FELL. ON THE COSTS NECESSARY
FOR THE BOARD MOM BUT SPENT
AND- AS AS DR WHIMS INDICATED
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCREASED
LEVELS OF SERVICE THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE WORKLOAD
ANALYSES. IT REMINDS ALSO
PROVIDES IS THE TIMING OF THE
FEE PAYMENTS TO COINCIDE WITH
THE FISCAL YEAR IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES DTS
HE'S FINDING. THIS WILL ALLOW
FOR FEE REVENUES TO BE
COLLECTED IN THE SAME FISCAL
YEAR AS THE EXPENDITURES ARE
APPROPRIATED AND THE FEES ARE
SET BY THE BOARD. ON THE VALUE
OF THIS IS THAT IT PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT WITH BETTER
CAPABILITIES TO MANAGE
RESOURCES INTO PREDICT REVENUES.
I MOST SIGNIFICANTLY INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS FOR OF SMALL
BUSINESSES TO FOSTER THE
RECOVERING FROM THE IMPACTS OF
THE PANDEMIC. BY CONTINUING
EXEMPTIONS FOR SMALL BUSINESS-
SMALL QUANTITY GENERATORS AND
EXPANDING THE EXEMPTION FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO THOSE LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. WHO
PAY- THE ENVIRONMENTAL FATE. DR
WILLIAMS AND I ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ON THE GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL
REFORM PACKAGE IN GENERAL FUND
BACK BILL BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ISSUE ARM ON FUNDING
TO ACCELERATE CLEAN UP AND
REVITALIZE AND I'M IN BERMAN
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. R. THANK
YOU HAVE A I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
LOTS OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- WE DIDN'T
RECEIVE THE- THE REPORT. ON
WHICH YOU MADE YOUR STATEMENT
TODAY ARE BASED YOUR STATEMENT
TODAY- UNTIL. AND WHEN I SAY WE
I MEAN OUR STAFF DIDN'T RECEIVE
THE TRAILER BILL REPORT UNTIL
FOUR THIRTY PM YESTERDAY AND
THIS IS AFTER MONTHS OF ASKING
FOR THE INFORMATION AND AS-
THAT YOU REFERENCED- A FAILED
ATTEMPT A YEAR AGO AND SO THIS
IS REALLY NOT A NEW ISSUE IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DELAYED TO THE LAST
MINUTE. AND WE'RE HERE. IN THIS
COMMITTEE. TRYING TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TO YOUR DEPARTMENT
BUT THERE'S NO WAY FOR US TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE DOCUMENTATION ON-
WHICH YOUR- UP OF VERBAL UP A
REPORT YOUR REPORT IS MADE
TODAY. SO. I DON'T. LIKE I JUST
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THIS- WE'RE IN A POSITION
WHERE. I CAN SAY HAVING
LISTENED TO HER REPORT IT ALL
SOUNDS GOOD BUT WE RELY ON OUR
OWN STAFF ANALYSIS TO ASK
QUESTIONS- AND TO PROBE- THE
REPORT THAT YOU MAKE. WE CAN'T
DO THAT WITHOUT THE WRITTEN
MATERIALS AND FOR US TO BE IN
THE SITUATION- I JUST I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE HERE. IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
THE MATERIALS WE NEED- AND
EVERYBODY KNEW THAT THIS
HEARING WAS HAPPENING WHEN IT
WAS GONNA HAPPEN. SO THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE FOR YOU IS
A GOOD. WAY TO TELL YOU MY
NOTES WHICH WERE WRITTEN- WHICH
I WROTE PRIOR TO FOUR THIRTY
YESTERDAY- THE ONE QUESTION
THAT I WAS GOING TO HAVE FOR
YOU IS THIS REPORT GOING TO BE
DUMPED ON US AT THE LAST
MINUTE- AND- SURE ENOUGH. OF
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
BOB SO CAN YOU RESPOND TO THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT
IS FUNDAMENTAL- FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE OVER OUR
OVERSIGHT. AND HOW OF THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE WITH THE TSC AND THE TRUST
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT- I HAD OF A REQUEST.
FOR FEAR REFORM AT WHICH I
THINK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BUT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A TWO
THIRDS VOTE. IN THE ASSEMBLY
SOMETHING WE REFERENCED EARLIER
HOW WAS STEEP A CLIMB THAT HAS-
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN ONE ANOTHER. AND
FRANKLY THIS IS NOT A
CONFIDENCE BUILDER- WHAT WE'RE
FACED WITH TODAY. IF I MAY
RESPOND I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU YEAH THIS IS MY DATE FOR
BEING CRANKY I'M SORRY. I THINK
I DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK
YOUR RESPONSES UNREASONABLE-
IT'S GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT WE WENT
THROUGH LAST YEAR IT CERTAINLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN IDEAL TO
PROVIDE THAT TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE TO YOU SOONER RATHER
THAN- YESTERDAY IN THE DAY YOU
KNOW LATE IN THE DAY AND SO.
MOVING FORWARD THE BEST WE CAN
DO IS BE AVAILABLE TO YOU TO
YOUR STAFF TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOUR CONCERNS ARE. AND
JUST TO START A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE REFORM IT IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE'RE NOT AN
IDEAL SITUATION NOTHING SEEMS
TO BE IDEAL THE STATE. BUT WE
WOULD LIKE. TO CONTINUE THE
ENGAGE AND I THINK. DO YOU THE
SAN ALL OF OUR- ALL RECOGNIZE
THE URGENCY OF THIS REFORM AND
REALLY WANT TO SEE IT COME TO
FRUITION BUT AS YOU INDICATED
VERY EARLY ON IT TO HAVE IT
LEFT. AND SO MOVING FORWARD WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND- GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE ARE HAVING
FRUITFUL DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BEFORE I CALL
IN LA- MISTER SMITH. YEAH KIND
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
FOR BRINGING THAT UP BECAUSE I
CALL IT A PAPER DUMP WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION TO
OF. BE AWARE OF THE SITUATION
BUT PRETTY MUCH YOU'RE GOING
FROM A FLAT FREE. TWO EIGHT
TIERED FEE. BUT TO MY CONCERN
IS IT'S GOING TO AFFECT. OFFICE
SIDE THAT WE'RE GOING AFTER THE
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS PRETTY
MUCH FOR PESTICIDES. BUT IT'S
GONNA AFFECT BLEACH
DISINFECTANTS. AND ALWAYS DOWN
TO THE OF. LAUNDRY DETERGENT.
THAT EVERYONE USES. SO I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE OPEN
DISCUSSION IN THE TIMING OF
THIS. BUT- THE BE DUMPED ON YOU
KNOW PROBABLY LESS THAN
FOURTEEN HOURS AGO. IN THE PAST
TO DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AGRICULTURE OF WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. IN THE COMMUNITY
BUT WE'VE HAD NO WARNING OF THE
PROPOSAL AND THERE'S BEEN NO
ENGAGEMENT. HOPE FROM AND IS
THIS TAX MEANT TO BE A TAX.
REVENUE GENERATOR OR IS IT
SENDING MARKET SIGNALS FOR MORE
OF OUR MANUFACTURERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE SALES OF THE
PESTICIDES TO DECREASE. IN THE
REVENUE IS INSUFFICIENT INTO
THE FUTURE. BUT THERE BE LOTS
OF QUESTIONS AND HOPEFULLY OF
IF THINGS DON'T CHANGE MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD SAY NO TO THIS
PROPOSAL THE SYSTEM RELATED TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. OFFICIALS SO-
IF YOU FIVE IS STILL COMING UP
TO BE HEARD BUT WE WILL. ACCEPT
THOSE COULD BE A YOU KNOW THE
MOST COMMON ONE IS AVAILABLE TO
ISSUE FIVE YOU'RE YOU'RE A-
YOUR ONE AND ONLY THIS ISSUE
BEHIND US ALL OF. MOVEON AG I
UNDERSTAND THAT- SO- PUT THOSE
COMMENTS ON HOLD AND APPLY THEM
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LET'S HEAR FROM LA- ALTHOUGH-
YOU KNOW READING THE- ALEJO
REPORT ON THIS OF THE WRITTEN
REPORT IT'S BASICALLY. IF WE
HAD A REPORT HERE'S ALL THE
QUESTIONS WE WOULD WANT TO SEE
ANSWERED AND- BUT PLEASE HELLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR-
FRANK MINUTES AGAIN WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YES AS YOU MENTIONED- TRAILER
BILL WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY SO
OUR OFFICE IS CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND I'M
RELEASING A FULL ASSESSMENT OF
THIS PROPOSAL AT A LATER DATE
SO WE ANTICIPATE RELEASE OUR
PART IN THE COMING WEEKS BUT AS
YOU MENTIONED IN THE MEANTIME
WE PROVIDED- STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE WITH- QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THE GOVERNANCE AND
FISCAL REFORM PACKAGE- BASED ON
THE THREE MAJOR COMPONENTS THAT
WE KNEW AT THE TIME AND THE P.
C. P. WAS PROVIDED TO US. THOSE
INCLUDE THE ESTABLISHMENT THE
BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY-
THE FEE RESTRUCTURED INCREASE
AND THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT AND THEN THE TAX
INCREASE THAT IS INCLUDED AND
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT. TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS I'M NOT
SEEING ANY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND YOUR
CARD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THE MOMENT
BUT HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR IS THE PROTECTING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FROM
TOXIC CHEMICALS CHEMICALS. YES
GOOD MORNING AGAIN A GERMAN
BLOOM THIS IS GRECO- DEPUTY OF
THE CLEANUP PROGRAM WILL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE- SITE DESCRIPTION CLEAN UP
AS WELL AS THE BROWNFIELD GRANT
PROPOSALS AND THEN- BUT
SHIFTING AGREE WILL BE.
PROVIDING A SUMMARY FOR THE
WORK TRAINING. PROGRAM THE
REQUEST. RIGHT IN THE REQUESTED
FOR A THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE GENERAL FUND THIS INCLUDES
THE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SENATE
EDUCATION CLEANUP PROGRAM
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BROWNFIELD GRANT PROGRAM AND
THEN FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
WORK. FORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
ASKED IN TERMS OF STAFF COSTS
TO ADMINISTER- THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN BUDGET YEAR
THE COMPANY CORPORATIONS AND-
NOW HERE'S FUNDING AS A
CORPORATE ENTITY IN THE-
PROPOSED FEE RATES- IN THE
TRAILER BILL. IT IS CONTINGENT
UPON ENACTMENT OF. THOSE
REFORMS. HE THE RATIONALE FOR
HE INVESTIGATION AND CLEANUP
PROGRAM IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
TOXIC WASTE SITES THREATEN
PUBLIC HEALTH. OF THE CAMPERS
OF THE REASON REDEVELOPMENT OF
PROPERTIES AND THEY HARM
EFFORTS TO REVITALIZE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
OVERBURDENED BY POLLUTION-
STATEWIDE THERE'S AN ESTIMATE
OF ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
BROWNFIELD SITES IN CALIFORNIA.
OTHER SOLUTION TO THIS IS TO DO
INVESTIGATION CLEANUP IN AREAS.
WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH IS
THREATENED AND WHERE
REVITALIZATION IS NEEDED. WE
WILL USE THE MOST FUNDS TO
ACCELERATE THE INVESTIGATION
CLEANUP OF CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES I'M IN INFORMAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES WERE
CURRENTLY- FOCUSED ON THE CUT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF AREAS
UNDER CALAVERAS SCREEN AND
AREAS THAT ALSO HAVE VERY HIGH
HOUSING NEEDS USING. BUT
APARTMENT HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT'S. HOUSING NEEDS
SURVEY. A WORLD TO COORDINATING
WITH H. C. H. C. D. ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE TOOLS THAT
WE WILL USE HOW WOULD
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM. I'LL
JUST QUICKLY SHIFTED TO THE
BROWNFIELDS PROGRAM SUMMARIZE
THAT- THE GRANTS WILL
ESSENTIALLY BE USED TO GO TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS
AND OTHER ENTITIES TO
INVESTIGATE AND CLEAN UP SITES
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL AS REVITALIZED ON.
COMMUNITIES GRANTS LEVERAGE
OTHER RESOURCES THE U. S. U. K.
ESTIMATES THAT ROUGHLY EVERY
DOLLAR- FROM THE BROWNFIELDS
PROGRAM RESULTED IN A TWENTY
TWENTY DOLLARS- IN THE EFFORT
TO INVESTIGATE AND CLEAN UP AND
ROUGHLY TEN DROPS OF EVERY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS INVESTED- AR
PROVIDED. BY THESE EFFORTS. WE
ARE ONCE AGAIN COORDINATING
WITH- H. T. T. AND INTERNALLY
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE DO IT REALLY
AS A KIND OF PIPELINE. THAT
WILL. INVESTIGATE SITES
REMEDIATE CONTAMINATION TO CUT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROVIDE RE
USE- OPPORTUNITIES AND THEN
HMD'S EFFORT ALSO A BUDGET
REQUEST. IN FISCAL YEAR I WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE- THE LAST THING
THAT I WOULD REFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THE PROFIT GRANT PROGRAM IS-
INVESTING MONEY NOW. IN
BROWNFIELDS CHANGE EVER
STRUCTURE EXPENSES AND PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL VIRAL DEGRADATION
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CREAMFIELDS- BECAUSE THESE
SITES ARE OFTEN LOCATED NEAR
SERVICES AND AMENITIES SUCH AS
JOB TRAINING CENTERS. SHOPPING
AREAS SCHOOLS HEALTHCARE
CENTRES- AND OTHER NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE REALLY DO
VIEW IT AS A- WIN WIN FOR
COMMUNITIES. I'M. SURE I'M NOT
HAND IT OVER TO- THANK YOU. FOR
POSTING TO FURTHER ENHANCE THE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS OF
BROWNFIELD BRANSON ORPHANS THAT
CLAIMS BY ESTABLISHING A
TRAINING AND SKILLS DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM. BY INVESTING AND THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING TO BUILD LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY AND
WORKFORCE EXPERTS DETAILS HE
WOULD DIRECTLY SUPPORT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
EQUITABLE JOB EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN LOCAL AREAS
WERE BROWNFIELD GRANTS ARE
AWARDED. THAT THE PROGRAM WOULD
BUILD ON THE SUCCESSES AND
LESSONS LEARNED OF SUPPORTING
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ON
THE EXIDE CLEANUP FOR MORE THAN
NINETY PEOPLE COMPLETED A
VARIETY OF TRAININGS OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. MORE THAN
SEVENTY OF THOSE GRADUATES HAVE
WORKED SIGNIFICAN HOURS ON THE
PROJECT WHICH MEANS THEY'VE
EARNED CERTIFICATIONS AND
EXPERIENCE TO HELP MEET THEIR
FUTURE. CAREER GOALS. IN THIS
INSTANCE WE WOULD ESTABLISH
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EXPERTS IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LEVERAGING THIS CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN PEOPLE
AND PROMOTE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- COMMUNITIES
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EXPERTS TO BUILD THE PROGRAM
WITH A FOCUS ON EQUITY THAT
MEETS ITS EACH REGION'S UNIQUE
WORKFORCE AND EDUCATIONAL NEEDS.
DEBBIE DR GRANT KOPEN I ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS. SO- MY
NOTES INDICATE THAT- PTSD IS
ACTIVELY WORKING ON SEVENTEEN
OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED SITES-
IS THAT ACCURATE. YES SIR
THAT'S ACCURATE. WE HAVE THE
JURISDICTION WE'VE GOT WORK AT
TOM BRADLEY SET SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED SITES ACROSS THE STATE-
WILL WILL SOME OF THE THEE
HUNDRED MILLION GO TO ADDRESS
THAT BACKLOG. ABSOLUTELY
CHARMING BLOOM- WE ANTICIPATE
THAT ROUGHLY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL BE YOU- FINISH THE
CLEANUP AT TWENTY TWO OR SITES.
THAT DTS HE IS CURRENTLY
WORKING ON. THE SITES ARE
LOCATED IN. THE TOP 25% OF TOWN
BY RISKY SCREEN COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS AREAS WITH VERY HIGH
HOUSING NEEDS UNDER H. C. D.'S-
HOUSING THE CIRCUIT. GREAT AND-
HOW MUCH OF THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DO YOU THINK THE TNC
CAN SPEND IN. ONE FISCAL YEAR.
IT'S A VERY GOOD- QUESTION. THE
THE AMOUNT REALLY DEPENDS ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FACTORS-
THE NUMBER OF GRANT
APPLICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVE-
THE RATE AT WHICH WE CAN HIRE-
AND TRAIN QUALIFIED STAFF TO DO
THE WORK. REALLY A LOT DEPENDS
TOO ON THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
SITES THAT WE INVESTIGATE- AND
POTENTIALLY CLEAN UP. SO THE
IMPORTANT THING WE'RE DOING NOW
WE ACTUALLY STARTED THIS- YOU
KNOW SEVERAL MONTHS AGO IS
WORKING TO PUT TOGETHER- THE
PLANS SEVEN PLANS PROTOCOLS
GUIDELINES THAT PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY FOUNDATION BUT
ESSENTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
RAPIDLY HIRING PEOPLE. FOR
GETTING GRANT- POSTAL'S READ
AGREE. AGGRESSIVE MADE WE'RE
TRYING FRONT LOAD THE PROCESS.
SO THAT SHOULD THE REQUEST BE-
PROVIDED FOR THIS COMING FISCAL
YEAR WE'RE READY TO GO ON DAY
ONE. WELL I CAN APPRECIATE THAT
BUT AT THE SAME TIME- YOU'RE
BRINGING FORWARD A REFORM
PROPOSAL- THAT WOULD KIND OF
CROSSOVER- THE PERIOD OF TIME
WITHIN WHICH THIS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED. IF IT IF THE
REFORM MOVES FORWARD SO WHAT
WHY NOT- FUND. THE AT NEXT
YEAR'S NEEDS. AND WAIT FOR THE
REFORM TO TAKE PLACE AND THEN
MOVE FORWARD LONG TERM AFTER
THAT. YEAH THAT'S THAT'S
ANOTHER EXCELLENT QUESTION- SO
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT IN OUR
WORK BUT WE BASICALLY- WE ARE
SITES ALL ACROSS THE STATE A
ROUGHLY HELLO YOU KNOW ONE OF
THREE PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN A MILE
OF THE SITE THAT WE WORK. AND
ABOUT 50% OF THOSE ARE INTERNAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES- FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE AND THAT'S REFLECTED
IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
COMMUNITIES NEED HELP NOW-
TOXIC WASTE SITES THREATEN
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THEY HAMPER-
REVITALIZATION EFFORTS WITHIN
COMMUNITIES- AS A REFERENCE
EARLY THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BROWNFIELD SITES
ACROSS THE STATE- ONCE AGAIN
FROM OUR EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT SENDS THOSE GOING
TO BE ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
COMMITTEES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY OVERBURDENED BY
POLLUTION- SO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS- I DON'T
FIGHT THESE FUNDS TO HELP
INITIATE THESE ACTIONS- TO
ASSIST THESE COMMUNITIES. WELL
I WON HER PERCENT AGREE WITH
YOU ON THE URGENCY OF- MOVING
FORWARD ON THESE PROJECTS. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. I THINK WE DID
A REPORT FROM L. A. L. AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN
FRAGMENTOS AGAIN WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE CANNOT HAVE A- FULL REPORT
OR ASSESSMENT ON- THE
BROWNFIELD CLEANUPS PROPOSAL
I'M THE MINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED THAT. THIS PROPOSAL
IS CONTINGENT ON IT MEANT OUR
LEGISLATURES ACCEPTANCE OF THE
PHYSICAL AND GOVERNMENT REFORM
PACKAGE WE FELT IT WAS
PREMATURE TO. PROVIDE A FULL
ASSESSMENT UNTIL TRAILER BILL
WITHOUT STEP. IN DISSIPATE
RELEASING A FULL REPORT ON THIS
ISSUE ALONG WITH THE REFORM
PACKAGE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
WELL IT PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF WITH- QUESTIONS THAT
WE FEEL THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER GOING FORWARD
AND ASSESSING THIS PROPOSAL
SUCH AS IDENTIFYING- THE
HIGHEST. TARGETED GOAL THE
DEPARTMENT HAS INDICATED THAT
BOTH FOR MEDIATION AND HOUSING
ARE ARE BOTH GOALS WHICH WE
FIND ARE WORTHWHILE ENDEAVORS
BUT- TARGETING A SPECIFIC GOAL-
WILL ENSURE THAT. THE FUNDS ARE
WELL TARGETED AND- PROVIDES
WHAT. WITH ADEQUATE OVER. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
YOUR MARCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS THANK YOU ARE
EITHER FOR YOUR- MISTER COPE-
ACTUALLY PROBABLY MR CONSTANCY
MADE THE TATEMENT ADDED I HEAR
ACCURATELY THAT ONE IN THREE
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN ONE
MILE OF THE TOXIC SITE. THAT
WE'RE WE HAVE DONE WORK THAT IS
CORRECT YEAH. THAT'S ONLY WHERE
YOU'VE DONE WORK SO THERE MAY
BE OTHER SITES WE HAVEN'T DONE
WORK. THAT WOULD. EXPAND THE
PROBLEM EVEN FURTHER. YES SIR
WHILE THAT'S A STARTLING AND
SHOCKING DATA POINT THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON TO A ISSUE FIVE.
THAT TRANSITION TO. SAFER
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
WE'VE GOT TO. ARMENPRESS THE
SAID REGULATION AND- FROM THE
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE QUEUED UP
FOR THIS ONE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BLOW AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANKS FOR HAVING
ME TODAY. MY NAME IS BATTLE
SCENE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. IF I MAY I'D LIKE
TO START A CONVERSATION WITH A
BRIEF STATEMENT ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED BUDGET
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT MISTER
SMITH RAISED ISSUE NUMBER THREE
ON THE NON PRESENTATION
CALENDAR THAT WAS FOR THE
KALPETTA STE. BCP PRO
REGISTRATION SYSTEM WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A PUBLIC WORKSHOP SIR
IN LATE MARCH ON THAT AND WOULD
BE HAPPY TO. CIRCLE BACK WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF WITH
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON. OUR
PRESENTATION TODAY WILL FOCUS
ON OUR P. C. P. TO REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE STATE'S
TRANSITION TO SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT.
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD REFERENCE
THIS IN HIS OPENING REMARKS.
AND I WOULD FURTHER AT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT FLAT FEE
MILLICENT SMITH ON PESTICIDE
SALES. WITH A RISK BASED TIERED
MELISSA SPENT. WHERE HIGHER
TOXICITY PESTICIDES ARSONIST A
HIGHER FEE. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS SENDS A STRONG MARKET
SIGNAL. OF CHIU AFFECTED. THE
BILL PAYERS AND WILL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT GOING FORWARD. ONCE
THIS NEW APPROACH IS FULLY
PHASED IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. AND AGAIN WE GAVE
A FOUR YEAR PHASE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FOR BILL PAYERS TO ADJUST
TO THIS NEW SYSTEM. THE TIERED
MIL APPROACH. INCENTIVES TO PAY
TO GENERATE APPROXIMATELY FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE ANNUALLY TO
THE DB ARE FUN. THE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES RAISED BY THE TIERED
MILL WILL FUND IMPORTANT DPR
AND CDFA PROGRAMS. YOU SEE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION CSU'S AG
RESEARCH INSTITUTE. WILL
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS FOR
THE WORK THAT THOSE ESSENTIAL
PARTNERS OF THE DEPARTMENT DO
ON LOCAL PESTICIDE USE AND
FORSMAN ACTIVITIES. IT WILL
ALSO ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO
ENGAGE MORE DEEPLY AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH PESTICIDE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
CALIFORNIANS AROUND THE STATE.
YOU KNOW SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF IMPORTANT WORK TO
ACCELERATE THE STATE'S
TRANSITION FROM. HARMFUL
PESTICIDES TO A SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE WAY TO MANAGE
PESTS. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
DPR AND CDFA AND OTHER AGENCIES
ARE DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THESE
HIGH PM ACTIVITIES. OF FROM
CHILD CARE CENTERS TO SCHOOLS
TO WORK THAT WE DO WITH LOCAL
GROWERS AROUND CALIFORNIA. BUT
THE REALLY GREAT NEWS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND
BACKYARD GARDENERS AND OPEN
SPACE MANAGERS AND MANY OTHERS.
HAVE BEEN UTILIZING IPM
PRACTICES. SINCE THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES. REPORTER PARTICULAR I
ABOUT THE SAID PERSON. AND
ALMOND GROWERS AND STRAWBERRY
GROWERS IN CALIFORNIA. ALL WHO
HAVE DEVELOPED IMPORTANT NEW
IPM TOOLS WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP IDENTIFY NEW
ALTERNATIVES SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVES. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE WEEKS AHEAD.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE FOR US- THANK
YOU OF IT MISTER SMITH DID YOU
WANT TO RESTATE SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS SO YOU GET AN ANSWER
TODAY OR I JUMPED EARLIER. OVER
EARLIER THANK YOU UP IN REGARDS
TO THE FLINT MILLER SETTLEMENT
GOING TO TIERED. MY QESTION IS
WHY HAVEN'T YOU ENGAGE THE OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE FARMING
COMMUNITY. WILL BE ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT NO WARNING
SO FAR. MISTER SMITH THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER
THAT WE HAVE ENGAGED A REALLY
PRETTY DEEPLY WITH OUR
AGRICULTURAL STAKEHOLDERS SINCE
WE ANNOUNCED THE BUDGET ON
JANUARY TENTH AND THEN WON.
SUPPLEMENTAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CAME OUT IN FEBRUARY I
WILL CONTINUE THAT ENGAGEMENT
IN FACT I'M GOING DOWN TO
FRESNO LATER THIS WEEK TO MEET
WITH THE GROUP DOWN THERE AND
I'M SURE THAT THIS TOPIC WILL.
COME UP WE'VE ALSO HAD SOME
REALLY GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS AND
CONSUMER PRODUCTS FOLKS. AS
WELL AS ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS IN
SACRAMENTO AND ELSEWHERE IN THE
STATE AND MANY OTHER
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL AND- AND
WANT TO LEARN MORE BUT I'M
ALWAYS HAPPY TO. ENGAGE FURTHER
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON QUESTIONS
LIKE THIS. AND WHAT WOULD BE-
THE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE. WITH
THE CELLS OF THE PESTICIDES
DECREASE. AND THE REVENUE OF
COMES UP IN SUFFICIENT IN THE
FUTURE. YEAH ANOTHER GOOD
QUESTION SIR YOU KNOW WE'VE
MADE SOME PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
ASSUMPTIONS WITH OUR
PROJECTIONS. RELATIVE TO YOUR
DIRECT QUESTION AND YOU KNOW
THE- TRAILS AROUND PESTICIDE
SALES HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN PRETTY
STABLE IN THE SIGNAL WORK
CATEGORIES THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
IN THIS PROPOSAL OVER THE LAST
FIVE OR MORE YEARS. AND FINALLY
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT RELATIVE
TO THE TEARING IT'S GOING TO
HAVE A LESS SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS AND A ONE
POINT 9% WILL BE THE INCREASE
THERE SO I BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
MADE SOME PRETTY GOOD
ASSUMPTIONS GOING FORWARD INTO
THE OUT YEARS. THANK YOU.
MISTER MULLIN AND THEN MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- JUST AT THE OUTSET I'D
SAY I'M GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TEARS- AND INCENTIVIZING.
THE USE OF PESTICIDES THAT THAT
DO THE LEAST HARM I CERTAINLY
THINK THAT'S A NOBLE GOAL THAT
THE QUESTION IS WHAT. MIGHT
SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BE I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME
ANSWERS- OPPONENTS ARE ARE
BEING VOCAL ON THIS ONE MAKE
SURE THAT APARTMENT IS ENGAGING
WITH THOSE FOLKS. CAN YOU
ARTICULATE FOR ME WHAT WHAT
SOME OF THOSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES MIGHT BE THAT THE
OPPONENTS ARE. SUGGESTING HERE-
I CERTAINLY THINK IT'S IN A
NOBLE EFFORT- THE QUESTION IS
YOU KNOW HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT
IN THE REAL WORLD DO WE
ACTUALLY GET THE- THE NET
RESULT AND THE APPROPRIATE
USAGE OF THE RIGHT KINDS OF
THESE- OF THESE PESTICIDES-
WHAT WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
CONVERSATION- RIGHT NOW WITH
SOME OF THE OPPONENTS. WELL
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION MISTER
MOLD YOU KNOW THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT NEED ON MY TEAM AND OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CDFA A PATH. THE
LAST NUMBER OF WEEKS WITH FOLKS
WHO. HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL ARE YOU KNOW. ABOUT
THE DETAILS AND WHAT THE SIGNAL
WORDS REALLY NEED THEM. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE FUNDS WILL BE
RAISED IN THE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES JUST TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE. INSIGHT INTO THE SIGNAL
WORDS THE SIGNAL WORD APPROACH.
WE DEVELOPED WAS USED BECAUSE
WE FELT THAT MOST RATE BUT MOST
REGISTRANTS AND MIL PLAYERS HAD
SOME FAMILIARITY WITH U. S.
EPA'S METHOD OF DEVELOPING
SIGNAL WORK SO WE HAVE NONE AND
CAUTION ON THE LESS TOXIC END
OF THE SPECTRUM WARNING IN THE
MIDDLE AND DANGEROUS
FLASHPOINTS AND ON THE FAR END.
AND WE REALLY THINK THAT THAT'S
A GOOD SOLID EASILY UNDERSTOOD
WAY OF DEVELOPING THIS NEW
TIERED MECHANISM ABOUT 63% OF
THE SALES IN CALIFORNIA FALL
UNDER THAT NON SLASH CAUTION
AND AGAIN THAT'S WHERE THE
SMALLEST IMPACT WILL BE IN
TERMS OF- IMPACTS ON
REGISTRANTS. I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT FOR NON SLASH CAUTION
WE'RE DEFERRING THE MILL
INCREASE FOUR YEAR BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED PRODUCTS THAT FALL
UNDER THAT CATEGORY IN THE
DEPARTMENT HAS REALLY BEEN GOOD
ABOUT EXPEDITING THE
REGISTRATION OF THOSE PRODUCTS
AND GETTING THEM TO MARKET FOR
INSTITUTIONAL GIVES. ABOUT
MIDDLE CATEGORIES ABOUT 14% BY
SALES AND THE DANGER SLASH
POISON IS 23% SO YOU KNOW MY
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD-
BEGINNING THE DAY THAT THE
BUDGET WAS ANNOUNCED AND MANY
SUBSEQUENT MEETING SINE THEN
WILL BE TO HEAR OUT THE
CONCERNS OF THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO THE IDEA. TRYING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS WHERE I CAN
SEE IF THEIR SUGGESTIONS FOR
YOU KNOW THINGS THAT MIGHT
TWEAK OUT CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL TO MAKE IT A MORE
EFFECTIVE ONE. AND TO
INCORPORATE. THAT INTO OUR
THINKING GOING FORWARD.
BRIGITTE ANSWERED THANK YOU.
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
OVER I CERTAINLY THE
DEPARTMENTS- CONCEPT HERE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S- SUPPORT FOR
THIS THE IDEA OF MOVING TO
TIERED STRUCTURES MAKES SIMPLE
COMMONSENSE WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO. ADD IS SEE IF WE COULD
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
ON THE ISSUE OF SUSTAINABILITY
OF THE FEES I THINK NO MATTER
WHERE WE ALL ARE- POLITICALLY
ALMOST EVERYBODY WOULD SAY IT
MAKES COMMON SENSE NOT TO RUN
DEFICITS I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
THINK SAID GOVERNMENT SHOULD
RUN DEFICITS OVERALL AND IF YOU
SHOULD RUN DEFICITS OVERALL YOU
SHOULD RUN DEFICITS IN
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT RUNS A DEFICIT. AND
THEN HAS TO TRY TO BORROW FROM
SOME OTHER DEPARTMENT OF MOTHER
FUND X. CENTER IN THE SECOND
CONCEPT THAT I THINK ALMOST
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE IS THAT
IF YOU ACCURATELY PRICED
SOMETHING FOR ITS OVERALL COST
YOU USE THAT PRODUCT MORE
EFFICIENTLY SO IF YOU ARE ABLE
TO JUST DUMP A BUNCH OF
EXTERNAL COST OFFER THE SORT OF
THE TRAGEDY OF THE COMMONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN SO MANY TIMES.
PEOPLE USE MORE OF SOMETHING
BUT IF THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY
PAY THE TRUE COST SO- IF YOU
COMBINE THAT WITH SOME PEOPLE
BENEFIT FINANCIALLY FROM THE
USE OF THE PESTICIDES THEY GET
TO GROW MORE CROPS MAKE MORE
PROFITS NOW I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT'S A BAD THING AT ALL AND
I'M NOT SUGGESTING IT'S BAD FOR
CONSUMERS CONSUMERS BENEFIT
ALSO BECAUSE THEY GET MORE FOOD
AT EXETER. BUT IF WE ACCURATELY
PRICE. THE TWO COST OF THE
PRODUCTION OF THAT PRODUCT WE
GET A MORE EFFICIENT ALLOCATION
OF THAT. AND SO- I'M NOT- THE-
OVERALL REALLY COMFORTABLE WITH
A FOUR YEAR PHASE IN BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS THE DEFICIT TO RUN UNTIL
THAT FOURTH YEAR. BUT I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT THE FOUR
YEAR PHASE IN BECAUSE I REALIZE
POLITICALLY IT IT HELPS PEOPLE
MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT. BUT WHAT I
AM CONCERNED WITH IS WHEN WE
FINISH THAT FOURTH YEAR- WE
WILL GO BACK TO WHAT
TRADITIONALLY HAS BEEN
HAPPENING WITH THIS DEPARTMENT.
THE LAST TIME THIS BILL FEE WAS
INCREASED WAS TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. NOW WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
COST OF RUNNING THE PROGRAMS
THE COST OF ENFORCEMENT. AND
MONITORING EXETER GRADUALLY
WENT UP AND UP AND UP AND THE
DEPARTMENT RAN A BIGGER BIGGER
DEFICIT IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
GOOD GOVERNMENT PRINCIPLES AND
COMMON SENSE WHILE WE MAY SAY
POLITICALLY WE PHASE IT IN. WE
SHOULDN'T STOP THAT AT THE FOUR
YEAR MARK. I THINK WE SHOULD.
BUILD IN SOME KIND OF. ALL OF
LIVING A JUST. AND I THINK WE
CAN BE CREATIVE ABOUT THAT IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE EXACTLY THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX EVERY YEAR
WHICH WOULD CAUSE SOME WEIRD
YOU KNOW PERCENTAGES BUT- MAYBE
YOU DO IT EVERY TWO YEARS MAYBE
YOU. BUT THAT THAT SHOULD BE A
PRINCIPLE THAT I THINK MOST OF
US COULD AGREE UPON BECAUSE- IT
IS IT JUST MAKES COMMON SENSE
IT WOULD KEEP THE DEPARTMENT
FOR RUNNING A DEFICIT MORE
CLOSELY MATCH REVENUES. TO
EXPENDITURES AND IT WOULD ALSO
GIVE US A CHANCE TO MORE
CLOSELY MATCH THE IMPACTS- AND
THEREFORE THE THAT THE COST OF
APPLICATION. SO I'VE HEARD THE
ISSUE RAISED. WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO WITH THE REVENUES ARE NOT
ENOUGH- YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE
INCREASED. COST WILL CAUSE A
REDUCTION IN THE USE OF THE
PESTICIDE. AND I WOULD OFFER TO
YOU. THAT'S A GREAT THING TO
HAPPEN. BECAUSE IF YOU DECREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PESTICIDE USE YOU
HOPEFULLY HAVE FEWER NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT AND
YOU SHOULD HAVE LESS
ENFORCEMENT. BEING NEEDED
XCERRA SO I WOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO- STRONGLY
CONSIDER SOME KIND OF COST OF
LIVING INDEX IF WE'RE GOING TO.
GO THROUGH THE CHALLENGE OF A
TIERED RATE INCREASE FOR- AND
WE'RE GOING TO PHASE IT IN THEN
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S THIS IS
THE PERFECT TIME TO TALK ABOUT
PHASING IN- OR THE FOR THE
PHASE IN CONTINUING WITH SOME
KIND OF COST OF LIVING
INCREASE. THAT WOULD BE OVERALL
GOOD GOVERNMENT FOR CALIFORNIA.
IF WE COULD DO THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND THE
LEGISLATURE I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT TO. THE IMBALANCES
ADDRESSED IN YEAR ONE ACCORDING
TO OUR PROJECTIONS YEARS
HOPEFULLY THAT TAKES CARE OF
THAT. PIECE OF THE ISSUE AND
THEN- YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING
TO LOOK AT PESTICIDE USE TRANS
AND- AND WHAT CATEGORIES ARE UP
AND WATER DOWN THE BACK AND
SAVE THAT FOR ANOTHER
CONVERSATION BUT- PAGE NOT ON
THIS ONE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. LET'S
HEAR FROM ALEJO AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I'M FRANK
JIMENEZ WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OVERALL WE
FIND THAT ADJUSTING THE
MELISSA'S BEEN IS WARRANTED
GIVEN THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
AND THE DEPARTMENT SPECIAL
FUNDS ALSO KNOWN AS THE TURN
BUTTON. YOU FIND AT
ESTABLISHING A TIERED MILL
ASSESSMENT OF PLACES A HIGHER
CHARGE THEM- MORE TOXIC
PESTICIDES IS REASONABLE AND
COULD ADDRESS ISSUES RELATED TO
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
PESTICIDE USE. AND OVERALL WE
FIND THAT THE GOVERNOR SPENDING
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL IS
REASONABLE GIVEN THAT AT LARGE
DATASETS THE STATE DIDN'T
REDUCING PESTICIDE USAGE AND
EXPANDS THE STATE'S EFFORTS AND
UPHOLDING PESTICIDE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. HOWEVER WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PHASE AND ANY CHAIRED MEL
ASSESSMENT AND ONE OR TWO YEARS
INSTEAD OF THE FOUR YEARS
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR. WE FIND THAT A FOR
YOUR FACE AN AS IS UNUSUALLY
LONG. AND ALTHOUGH WE RECOGNIZE
THIS THE FAITH AND WOULD REDUCE
SHORT TERM COST THE BUYERS AND
SELLERS OF PESTICIDES- IT WOULD
HAVE SOME NOTABLE DRAWBACKS IT
POTENTIALLY CREATES A WEAKER
MARKET SIGNAL FROM THE START
SINCE THE- EIGHTH IT'LL BE.
SLOWER AND THEN USING A SLOWER
AND GENERATES. REVENUES UP
FRONT WHICH REQUIRES GENERAL
FUND TO COVER PROPOSED SPENDING
AS SEEN IN A PROPOSAL. AN
ANALYSIS WE PROVIDE- THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ALTERNATIVE
PAID THINGS THAT USE THE SAME
RATES OF THE GOVERNOR BUT OUR
IMPLEMENTED AND- A ONE YEAR
PHASE IN A TWO YEAR PHASE AND
WE THINK THAT- THAT ALIGNS.
REVENUES WITH SPENDING AND ALSO
PROVIDES THE LEGISLATURE MORE
FLEXIBILITY. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE LINE AND A
NEW SPENDING WITH THE RATE AT
WHICH REVENUES ARE GENERATED.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL HAVE
NO REVENUES- TO FULLY FUND
PROPOSED SPENDING. A MINUTE
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE MORE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO THE DPR
FIND- WE ALSO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH TO- GREATER
POLICY QUESTIONS FIRST IS- THE
NOTION OF SIGNAL WORD- GET
MINISTRATION IS. PROPOSING TO
BASE ITS YOUR TAX ON SIGNAL
WORD. WHICH INDICATES A
PRODUCTS- ACUTE TOXICITY LEVEL.
AND SPEAKING WITH EXPERTS IN
THE FIELD ACUTE TOXICITY
DOESN'T NECESSARILY CORRELATE
WITH. CHRONIC TOXICITY OR A
LARGER ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS.
SO THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES THAT
ADDRESS A BROADER BROADER RANGE
OF PESTICIDE RELATED CONCERNS.
AND WHETHER- RATE SHOULD
REFLECT REVENUE TARGETS ARE
MARK NICK PARK MARKET SIGNAL-
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED RATES
WOULD FULLY FUND THE PROPOSED
SPENDING ONCE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. ON A DRESS THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT- HOWEVER
UPON FULL IMPLEMENTATION THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE HIGHEST
AND LOWEST TIER WILL BE ROUGHLY
2% IN TERMS OF PRICE. AND WE
FIND THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY
SMALL PRICE DIFFERENCE SO IT
WOULDN'T HAVE A LARGE EFFECT ON
THE- THE MIX OF PESTICIDES USED
IN THE STATE. SO THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT CONSIDER- A
DIFFERENT RATE STRUCTURE THAN
BEING PROPOSED. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUES- SECURE STEAM IS
ALSO ON THE LINE AND ANSWER ANY
OF YOUR- DIRECT TAX RELATED
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU QUESTIONS
THIS IS JUST ABOUT. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO COMPLEMENT THE L.
A. ILL IN IN TERMS OF THEIR
ANALYSIS AYE- AS I READ THIS
AND IN PREPARATION I THOUGHT.
VERY GOOD INSIGHTS- TALKING
ABOUT A 2% DIFFERENCE AND IS
THAT GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO
ROUTE TO REALLY REFLECT THAT
THE DIFFERENT IMPACTS IN TERMS
OF TOXICITY- THE SAME THING
WITH. USING THE SIGNAL WORDS-
IS THERE A BETTER IT'S LIVE
VERY LEGITIMATE TO RAISE I
BELIEVE ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
THE L. A. O. WAS RAISED- MY
QUESTION SIMPLY IS
IMPLEMENTATION IF WE TRIED TO
ADOPT ALL OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE ALEJO-
IT. IT MAY MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO ACTUALLY
PULL THIS OFF AND SO- IF YOU'D
TALK ABOUT ENGAGING THE HEAVY
LIFT- SOMETIMES YOU GET TO SING
TO PROVE. BUT I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR RAISING
THOSE I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY INSIGHTFUL-
OBSERVATIONS. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
TO ADMIT AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. AND I'M SEEING NONE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS THE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AGRICULTURE AT THE GRIP
FOR ISSUES BEGINNING WITH ISSUE
NUMBER SIX CALIFORNIA FARM TO
SCHOOL INCUBATOR GRANT PROGRAM.
IT IS A FABULOUS PROGRAM.
THAT'S GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
LOAN THIS IS JENNY LESTER
MOFFETT AND I'M UNDERSECRETARY
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE HI I'M- BERMAN
AVVENIRE CULTURES REQUESTING
TEN MILLION IN GENERAL FUND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FARM TO SCHOOL
INCUBATOR GRANT PROGRAM. THE
FUNDING WILL BUILD ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PILOT
TWENTY BUDGET ACT TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA FARMERS
AND EXPAND HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS
BY PROVIDING GRANTS TO SCHOOLS.
AND TO ESTABLISH PROGRAMS THAT
COULD MAKE LOCAL IN CALIFORNIA
GROWN PROCUREMENT AND
UTILIZATION IN SCHOOL MEALS.
WHEN THE CURRENT TWENTY MILLION
I SEE A RECEIPT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. WE HAVE A
FRIEND THAT'S A EXPANDED
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA FARM
TO SCHOOL NETWORK. AND WE HAVE
LAUNCHED A CALIFORNIA FARM TO
SCHOOL WORKING GROUP I'VE STATE
LEADERS WHO COLLABORATE AND
ALEVE AND SOLVES SYSTEMATIC
PROBLEMS MAKING PART OF THE
SCHOOL AND EDUCATION.
IMPORTANTLY EIGHT AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED
TO THE CALIFORNIA FARM TO
SCHOOL THANK YOU PETER GRANT
PROGRAM. WE RECENTLY CLOSED
THAT REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL FOR
THE GRANT PROGRAM AND I'M PROUD
TO SHARE WITH YOU GUYS TODAY.
THAT WE HAD EIGHTY APPLICATIONS
AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS APPLY. FOR
TOTAL REQUEST SEPT TWELVE
POINTS YOU MILLION DOLLARS. THE
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT FOOD IN AG
EDUCATION IN CLASSROOMS
CAFETERIAS AND THROUGHOUT
EXPERIMENTAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND SCHOOL
GARDENS ON FARMS AND OTHER
CULINARY AND AGRICULTURAL
PATHWAYS. THIS PROJECT WILL
INCREASE LOCAL PROCUREMENT AND
IN COLLABORATION BETWEEN
REGIONAL FARM JUST FOR PARTNERS.
BY CONTINUING THE FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FARM TO SCHOOL
INCUBATOR GRANT PROGRAM CDFA IS
OFFICE OF FARM WORK WILL BE
ABLE TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEEN GAUGED IN
PARKS WHAT PROGRAMMING LEADING
TO INCREASED ADOPTION OF
HARMFUL PRACTICES. A GREATER
IMPACT FOR CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST
NEED COMMUNITIES AND ONGOING
SUCCESS FOR SCHOOLS FARMERS IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT- TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. DO YOU HAVE- TWELVE
MILLION- IN GRANT APPLICATIONS
THAT WERE APPROVED. THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED WE ARE REVIEWING
THOSE APPLICATIONS NOW GOT IT
OKAY BUT YOU'RE LIMITED TO
EIGHT A HALF MILLION UNDER THE
CURRENT BUDGET. CORRECT GREAT
THAT SAID OVERSUBSCRIBED. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE- I'LL JUST ADD A
COMMENT- I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM IT'S ONE THAT
THERE'S CLEARLY BY THE UC
STATISTICS A LOT YOU JUST GAVE
US THERE'S ROOM FOR GROWTH- AND
THAT'LL BE A GOOD THING FOR
FARMERS GOOD THING FOR SCHOOLS
GOOD THING FOR THE HEALTH OF
THE CHILDREN OF OUR STATE. THE
STRUCTURE OKAY JUST ECHO ANY
LAWYER YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT HOW
GOOD THE PROGRAM IS I'VE I SEE
FIRSTHAND THIS PROGRAM- USED
AND IN MANY PLACES MANY OF THE
SCHOOLS AND IT'S JUST
OUTSTANDING I THINK THE IMPACT
IT'S HAVING THANK YOU. MS RIVER.
AB NIGHTS WHATEVER MAY UP- ON
THE HOUSE. SUPPORTIVE I AM
ABOUT OF THIS PROGRAM I THINK
IT. IT TEACHES CHILDREN
NUTRITION AT A YOUNG AGE WHICH
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT A LOT
OF CHILDREN RELY ON SCHOOL
LUNCH. ON TO EAT EVERY DAY- AND
THIS COULD BE THE HEALTHIEST
MEAL THAT THEY ARE GETTING AT
SCHOOL. AND SO I'M VERY PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS ITEM. GET A LOT
OF KUDOS FOR THIS PROGRAM. SO
KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A REPORT FROM A LA-
OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRIME MINISTER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THIS IS- ITEM RAISE NO CONCERNS
FOR US. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FIND THAT THAT'S THE THING YES
THE GENERAL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WERE HAPPY TO HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT DON'T
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE
AT THE MOMENT. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN NOW. IMPACT
ASSESSMENT ALIGNMENT OF
REGULATORY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR AGRICULTURE I
THINK IT'S THE MOST WALKIE
TITLE. MANY OF OUR REPORTS
TODAY. YEAH YEAH THANK YOU-
YES- PRIOR TO KOBE NINETEEN
FARMERS AND RANCHERS WERE
FACING INCREASING YOU
CHALLENGES INCLUDING THINGS
LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE WATER AND
CERTAINTY A NUMBER OF NEW
REGULATION SENATE PASSED IN THE
PAST DECADE BETTER NOW BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS. AND MANY OF THESE COME
WITH SEPARATE RECORDING
REQUIREMENTS A FEW YEARS AGO AT
CDFA WE HAD A GRADUATE STUDENT
FROM THE GOLDMAN SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS WHO MAPPED OUT THE
NUMBER OF REGULATIONS THAT
FARMERS OF ALL SIZES MUST
COMPLY WITH. AND BE IDENTIFIED
AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS ACROSS MULTIPLE
STATE AGENCIES. I KNOW THAT
WHEN I GO OUT AND SECRETARY
ROCKETS OUT WHEN THE GOVERNOR
GOES OUT NEED TO FOR HOURS. WE
OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THIS
REGULATORY BURDENS. IT'S REALLY
ABOUT THE COMPLEXITY AND THE
COST OF COMPLIANCE. AND THE
MANY REPORTS THAT ARE DUE AT
DIFFERENT TIMES OPTING OUT IN
ASKING FOR THE SAME OR SIMILAR
INFORMATION. TO BE SENT TO
MULTIPLE AGENCIES. HAVE KIND OF
THAT ARE VERY COMPLEX TITLE- IN
THIS PROJECT- AT THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC WHEN RESTAURANTS
CAFETERIAS EVENTS AND
HOSPITALITY CLOSE. NEARLY HALF
THE FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN HALTED
COMPLETELY. AS WE LOOK AT
RECOVERING FROM THE HUGE
DISRUPTION IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
WE KNOW THAT A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT. OF OUR SMALL FARMERS
WERE IMPACTED. SO AS PART OF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE AT CDFA
HER COLLEAGUES THAT COUNTY PA.
ARE REQUESTING FOUR MILLION
CURRENT YEAR TO HIRE A
CONSULTANT CAN MANAGE A PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT AND MAP OUT
THOSE REGULATIONS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. AND IDENTIFY I.
Q. KEY AREAS WHERE WE CAN
JOINTLY EMBARK. TO ALIGN AND
STREAMLINE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. IN ADDITION TO THE
JOINT COUNTY PETE CDFA HOW ETA
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
CDFA IS ALSO REQUESTING TWO
MILLION AND BUDGET YEAR
TARNISHING AND I. T. BUSINESS
ASSESSMENT TO EXPLORE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A UNIFIED LIFE
THING FOR PORTAL. FOR FIFTY TWO
LICENSE TYPES ACROSS THIRTY
EIGHT PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT. NEEDS TO PROD ARE
ABOUT IMPROVING OUR CUSTOMER
SERVICE TEAM LIFE A LITTLE BIT
EASIER FOR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL AND
UNDERSERVED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
COSTS BECAUSE THEY ARE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE A DEDICATED
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF. TO DO ALL
OF THAT REGULATORY REPORTING-
AND MORE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE DIVERSIFIED OPERATION. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS A STARK
STRAWBERRY SPECTOR COMMISSIONED
THE STUDY ESTIMATED AT LEAST 7%
OF THEIR OPERATING COSTS WERE
JUST AROUND THE COMPLAINTS
RECORDING COSTS. ARE SEPARATE
PRODUCERS. REDUCING THESE COSTS
BY STREAMLINING STATE REPORTING
PROCESSES ACROSS AGENCIES. OUT
COMPACT COMPROMISING
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IS URGENTLY NEEDED TO HELP
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ESPECIALLY
SMALL AND UNDERSERVED FARMERS
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING TO RECOVER
FROM THE FINANCIAL IMPACT. OF
THE NINETEENTH AND HELP THE
STATE MARK EQUITABLY SERVE
SMALL ARMS. THANK YOU AND HAVE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE REPORT- AND-
KUDOS TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR.
RECOGNIZING THIS ISSUE AND TO-
TAKING STEPS TO ADDRESS IT I
THINK IT'S A- IT IT IT SAYS A
LOT ABOUT- HOW YOU APPROACH THE
VERY IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT. HAS ARE
THERE ANY- OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- OF THE LA OVER A
DEPARTMENT FINANCE COMMENTS.
THANKS RESEARCH I AM PREGNANT
AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- AS PART OF A
LAST MINUTE WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
PROPOSAL TO CONDUCT AN
ASSESSMENT OF REGULATORY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. I'M NOT
A PLACE ON AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
AND ALWAYS FIND THAT ASSESSMENT
OF THIS NATURE HAS MERIT- AT
THE TIME THE ADMINISTRATION DID
NOT PROVIDE US WITH A
COMPELLING LIST OF DUPLICATIVE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IT
INTENDS TO ASSESS. HAVING THIS
INFORMATION PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE- CONFIDENCE THAT
THE PROBLEM DOES EXIST AND THAT
FUNDING WILL BE WELL TARGETED.
BUT I'M MORE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT AND THE COMMITTEE-
REVIEWING. THAT INFORMATION
DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED TODAY-
ON THE ONLINE. PORTAL WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED DEPARTMENT TO REPORT
AT BUDGET HEARINGS ON. I'M
OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS THAT COULD
BE USED- WE FIND THAT ASSESSING
THE ONLINE PAYMENT PORTAL- IS A
REASONABLE SENSE IT DOES. IT IS
SEEN AS OVER BURDENSOME TO
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY. HOWEVER
THE ASSESSMENT LARGELY BENEFITS
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY M. AND AS
A PROVIDE A WIDE ENOUGH PUBLIC
BENEFIT TO. CLEARLY NECESSITATE
GENERAL FUND. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FRAZIER
MEMBERS THIS IS ANDREW HOLTZ
APARTMENT FINANCE I'M THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
THE GENERAL FUND IS MORE
APPROPRIATE FUNDS SOURCE IN
THIS CASE- IT ALIGNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OVERALL
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY WHICH IS
CONTINUING TO FACE MANY
CHALLENGES AND THIS IS PART OF
AN OVERALL PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES THREE ETERNITY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE. WE
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THERE
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES FOR
CDFA. TO DETERMINE HOW TO
EQUITABLY SPREAD- THESE FEES
ACROSS THE INDUSTRY UNDER THE
VARIOUS TYPES OF. REPAIRS INTO
THE FUNDS. THANK YOU FOR SHARE
THOSE COMMENTS. LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
FAIRGROUNDS. THANK YOU CHAIR
I'M GOING TO INTERVIEWS- MY
COLLEAGUE DEPUTY SECRETARY
KEVIN MASAHARU IS GOING TO
INTRODUCE THE TOPIC. A GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- FOR THE RECORD
KEVIN MASU HARD AT THE
SECRETARIAT CDFA PRINT
MINISTRATION AND FINANCE. I'M
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THE
FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ITEM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
STATE AFFILIATED FAIRS IN TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR THE NETWORK
AFFAIRS. AT THE TWENTY TWENTY
GLOBAL PANDEMIC RESULTED IN A
COMPLETE SHUT DOWN. BEING THE
MAIN DRIVER THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DERIVE
REVENUES. INSIDE HAD A VERY
VERY SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION AND
ALL THE REVENUES THAT THEY-
WERE ANTICIPATING TO ACCRUE TO
THEM IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN
ALSO AS WE MOVE INTO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SEASON WERE FACING
THE SAME CONDITIONS- BUT IT'S
NOTEWORTHY THAT WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT- THE REVENUE DROPPING
OFF LIKE THAT WERE NOT MET
WITH. EQUAL REDUCTIONS TO THE
EXPENDITURES THAT THEY FACED A
WE DID ADDRESS THAT LAST YEAR
WITH A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION TO HELP STATE
AFFILIATED FAIRS NAVIGATE AWAY
OFF PROCESS TO STOP PRODUCTION.
IT DOES IN OTHER EXPENSE
STATEMENTS THAT STRATEGY LIKE
THAT AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO FACE THOSE
CHALLENGES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. HOWEVER DUE TO THE
FAIRGROUNDS ROLE IN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND SUPPORT MAY
SERVE AS- A MYRIAD OF DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS. EVERYTHING FROM THE
BACK YOU AGENTS CENTERS TO A
CODE NINETEEN VACCINATION SITES
AND- WARMING CENTERS AND MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS. BUT IT'S
PARAMOUNT THAT WE PROVIDE
ENOUGH OPERATIONAL SUPPORT TO
KEEP THEM UP AND RUNNING AND TO
MAKE THEM VIABLE AS ASSETS. IN
WERE ALSO IT WITHIN THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT'S GOING TO BE USED TO
ASSESS THE FAIR GROUNDS FOR
POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVE USES. AND
NOT JUST ALSO UNDERSCORES THE
FACT THAT THERE IS NO STATUS
QUO THESE DAYS AND THAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR OTHER ALTERNATIVES
TO DO TO TRY TO MITIGATE SOME
OF THE SITUATIONS THAT I
ENCOUNTERED. I'M AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE THE PLAN IMPORTANT ROLE
DURING CATASTROPHIC EVENTS AND
SERVE MANY DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS.
YES SO THAT TEN MILLIONDOLLARS
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALSO
IS PART OF THAT. THESE ARE ALL
VERY AGING STATE ASSETS AND-
RECENT SURVEYS THAT SHOWN THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY. ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT
COULD BE DONE IF THOSE UNDS
WERE AVAILABLE SO AT TEN
MILLION IS JUST SMALL START
TOWARDS THAT IN THAT DIRECTION
TO DO THAT. AND WITHOUT. ALL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT I MISS MAFI HARA- WHEN-
WHEN I HAVE A FAIR GROUND IS
USED- BY THE STATE- IF FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN- CAL FIVE SETS UP
A INCIDENT COMMAND CENTER IS
THERE A REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS-
TO THE TO THE FAIR OR IS THAT.
JUST MADE AVAILABLE AND TO
OTHERS NO TRANSFER OF FUNDS.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND
ACTUALLY IS A MORE COMPLICATED
QUESTION THAN YOU PROBABLY
THINK ON THE SURFACE. THERE
SOME THINGS DEPENDING ON THE
USE THERE IS NOT A COST
RECOVERY OPPORTUNITY- BUT WHEN
THE MONEY COMES IN AND OUT
PROVIDES THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIM AREIMBURSEMENT. AND THEN
ALSO IN CERTAIN INSTANCES OTHER
MONEY COMES IN FROM NONPROFITS
LIKE THE RED CROSS TO PROVIDE
SHELTER AND SERVICES MY PEOPLE
ARE DISPLACED. AND SO THE
ANSWER IS THAT YES THERE IS
SOME COST RECOVERY- BUT IT'S
NOT AS STRAIGHTFORWARD AS YOU
MIGHT THINK IT IS AND THERE ARE
WE DO END UP WITH COSTS THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE RECOVERED
DURING EMERGENCY EVENTS I SEE
OKAY THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS.
THE L. A. O. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- YOU RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION
ON THE OPERATIONAL SUPPORT FOR
STATE AFFILIATED FARES UNTIL
THE MAY REVISION. I ALWAYS FIND
THAT PROVIDING OPERATIONAL
SUPPORTERS REASONABLE SINCE
FARES HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
CONDUCT THEIR NORMAL REVENUE
GENERATING ACTIVITIES. OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE
ASSUMES THAT PAIRS WILL BE
UNABLE TO CONDUCT OPERATIONS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- WE FOUND THAT
THERE IS STILL UNCERTAINTY
REGARDING THIS GIVEN THAT
SOCIAL. DISTANCING GUIDELINES
MIGHT BE UPDATED AS MORE PEOPLE
ARE VACCINATED. WE BELIEVE THAT
DELAYING A DECISION ON THIS
ITEM BUT ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO USE THE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
INFORM ITS DECISION ON THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT TO PROVIDE-
OF THE FORTY SEVEN MILLION THAT
IS BEING PROVIDED FOR-
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT. THE
DEPARTMENT IS INDICATED THAT
HALF WILL BE. TARGETED BASED ON
FINANCIAL NEED OF THE FARES AND
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS. I RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED
THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO RELEASE OF
THE FUNDS. HAVING A THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATION WILL PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT. AND TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING IS TARGETED BECAUSE
THESE FUNDS ARE LIKELY TO BE.
ADJUSTED METHODOLOGIES ARE
LIKELY TO BE ADJUSTED AS WELL
AS MORE FINANCIAL INFORMATION
IS MADE AVAILABLE ON THE FARES-
AND THE NOTIFICATION SHOULD
INCLUDE THE AMOUNT PROVIDED TO
EACH STATE AFFILIATED FAIR. THE
METHOD OF THE ADMINISTRATION
USED TO ALLOCATE FUNDING. ANY
REMAINING BALANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENTS EXPECTED USE OF
THAT BALANCE. ON THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED. FUNDING FOR THIS
REQUEST- THERE'S PROVIDE-
HARDENS THE RESPONSE FOR THE
STATE AND- DEMONSTRATION HAS
INDICATED THAT. THERE AND SHOWN
THAT THERE'S- THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEED AMONGST THE
NETWORK AFFAIRS. THANK YOU
FORMER FINANCE. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBER THIRTY LAGGED OVER
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- JUST
A COUPLE POINTS- YOU KNOW I
THINK WE GET THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE ARE. THE ON ON YOU KNOW
WHAT DIRECTIVITY THE FARES MAY
BE ABLE TO- CONDUCT NEXT YEAR
JUST GIVEN THE- OVERALL
UNCERTAINTY THE ON THE
COMMUNITY EVENT THAT MAKE- I
THINK YOU KNOW THE ESTIMATE
BASED OFF OF THE- AVAILABLE
INFORMATION DATA AND WE HAVE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- IN TERMS
OF- THE COMMENT ON. THE
NOTIFICATION PRIOR TO RELEASE
IF THE FUNDING YEAH I THINK WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ON. THAT
LIMITING IN THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION FLEXIBILITY TO
ACT QUICKLY. PROVIDE AFFAIRS
FUNDING THE IN A QUICK MANNER
ONE THING WE'VE LEARNED THIS
YEAR IN THE CURRENT YEAR WITH
PROVIDING- THE MONEY TO THE
FAIR IS THERE ARE A LOT OF.
EXPECTED BEING THAT HAPPENED
BUT WE DO NEED TO ACT QUICKLY.
AND PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE FAIR
AND SO GIVEN THAT THEY ARE
WORKING ON ON TIGHT BUDGETS.
ARE THERE THERE IS SOME CONCERN
THERE ON- CAN REDUCING THAT
FLEXIBILITY. SO WHEN IT COMES
TO THE- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
PROJECTS THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE
THOSE- SHOVEL READY TO THE
EXTENT OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S REQUESTED. THE QUESTION
MAKE SENSE. MISTER CHAIR I CAN
HANDLE THAT QUESTION AND YET AS
I INDICATED BEFORE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE RELATIVE PROPORTION
OF THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND IDENTIFY NEEDS OUT
THERE- THERE ARE A LARGE NUMBER
OF SHOVEL READY PROD PROJECTS
THAT WE COULD PUT THE MONEY
TOWARDS VERY QUICKLY- BUT I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE THE ILLUSION
THAT IT'S EASY TO DO THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLES SO THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE PROPER
CONTROLS IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THE MONEY GOES TOWARDS THOSE.
SO IT'S YEAH WE DON'T SNAP OUR
FINGERS AND DISTRIBUTE THE
MONEY FOR THE PROJECTS WE HAVE
A REVIEW PROCESS THAT WE LOOK
AT THE PROJECT AND WE EVALUATE
AND COMPARED TO A LOT OF OTHER
FACTORS WE ALSO GET DGS
INVOLVED TOO BECAUSE THEY HAVE
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA WE DON'T
HAVE- BUT YEAH THE PROJECTS A
LOT OF THEM HAVE BEEN IN THE
QUEUE FOR SO LONG THAT I WOULD
CHARACTERIZE THAT SHOVEL READY.
SO WHO- THE THAT THAT PROCESS
THAT YOU REFER TO. IF WE WERE
TO ALLOCATE MONEY NOT THAT WE
CAN DO IT BUT IF WE WERE TO DO
IT TODAY- THAT PROCESS WOULD
BEGIN. SOON AFTER TODAY. AS
OPPOSED TO IF IT'S IN THE-
UPCOMING YEAR'S BUDGET. IT
CAN'T- THAT PROCESS WOULDN'T
BEGIN UNTIL THE FISCAL YEAR
BEGINS WITH IS THAT.
ESSENTIALLY CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUTIS THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR
AND RECEIVED BIRD MAINTENANCE
FUNDING. WE'VE DONE SO IN THE
PAST I BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT
ELEVEN TO TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
PRIOR FISCAL YEARS. AND SO WE
HAVE BUILT PROGRAMMATIC
EXPERTISE ON GETTING THE
PROCESS STARTED SO WE ARE WE
KNOW WHAT TO ASK FOR THE FERRIS
OF WORK THROUGH THIS BEFORE SO
THEY KNOW WHAT INFORMATION TO
PROVIDE TO US BUT THOSE
VALUATIONS THAT I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY. SO YOU I DON'T I
DON'T WANT YOU TO THINK THAT
ALLOCATING THIS AND BUDGET YEAR
MEANS THAT WE START SOMETHING
FROM SCRATCH WHAT WE DO IS WE
CONTINUE ON WITH SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE DONE IN THE PAST. A LOT
OF THE- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS
ARE A- DEFECT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES ARE A-
RESTAURANT. TYPE OF ISSUES.
THANKS AND TOILETS AND THAT
KIND OF THING. THAT RIGHT YOU
KNOW IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE
YEAH THERE ARE SOME ADA
COMPLIANCE ESPECIALLY IN
RESTAURANTS- ONE THING WITH A
LOT OF THESE FAIRGROUNDS BEING
PULLED INTO EMERGENCY RESPONSE
THAT CAME UP IS THIS LACK OF
FOOD PREPARATION FACILITIES AND
THEN ALSO NOT JUST EIGHTY EIGHT
BUT ADEQUATE RESTAURANTS THAT
PROVIDE SHOWERING FACILITIES
FOR PEOPLE WHO END UP HAVING TO
SPEND DAYS AND SOMETIMES WEEKS.
BEING UNDER EVACUATION ORDERS
SO YEAH THERE'S A LOT OF THOSE
TYPES OF PROJECTS AND SOME OF
THEM RUN TO VERY BASIC THINGS
LIKE REPAIRING ROADS SO THAT
THEY DON'T LEAK DURING THE
RAINY SEASON AND REPAIRING
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
WIRING OR- SEWER SYSTEMS OR
WATER SUPPLY PIPES. HEATING UP
OPEN SURFACES OF THE EQUIPMENT
DOESN'T GET STUCK WHEN THEY'RE
USING AS A STAGING GROUND SO
YEAH THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PROJECTS OUT THERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROJECT TYPES. TO
INTERCEPT A COHORT OF-
ESSENTIALLY EARLIER THAT THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN EARLY
ACTION REQUEST- SO THAT YOU CAN
GET STARTED ON THIS PROJECT AS
SOON. AS POSSIBLE- TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS A PRETTY ROUND
NUMBER. I SUSPECT THAT THERE'S-
ATYR CAPACITY THAT IF THEY'RE A
LARGER ALLOCATION YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD- RAPIDLY
AS YOU CAN WITH THOSE THAT ARE.
ASSUMED TO BE UNDER THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS YOU'D BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD A RAPIDLY ON
THOSE AS WELL IF WE WERE TO
FULLY FUND TO ACCOMMODATE. ALL
OF THOSE NEEDS THAT COULD BE
HANDLED IN THE IN THE NEAR TERM.
ASSEMBLY WHAT WOULD THAT NUMBER
BE. YEAH I KNEW YOU WERE GOING
IN THAT DIRECTION AND I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE I'M NOT PREPARED TO
GIVE YOUR RESPONSE RIGHT NOW-
IT WOULD BE MORE THAN THE TEN
MILLION OBVIOUSLY AS I'VE
INDICATED BEFORE- BUT ONCE WE
MOVE BEYOND THAT IN SOME OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE HAD NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THE
PREVIOUS ALLOCATIONS OF FUNDING
THAT I MENTIONED BEFORE- THEN
WE WOULD HAVE TO CONSIDER A
WHOLE HOST OF NEW PROJECTS
THAT. WE WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE REVIEW PROCESS- SO.
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO ANYTHING
TODAY- BUT IF YOU CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CERTAINLY AS CHAIR I WOULD
LOOK FAVORABLY ON- IN A IN A IN
A YEAR WHEN WE- ARE BLESSED
WITH A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ONE TIME MONEY- THAT THE
FAIRGROUNDS. IN ADDITION TO ALL
THE HISTORICAL USES- UGH UGH
THAT THEY'VE BEEN PUT TO ARE. A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
STATE THAT- TYPICALLY DON'T GET
A LOT OF ATTENTION. THE THEY
NEED TO BE READY ON A MOMENT'S
NOTICE TO SERVE AS YOU
DESCRIBED A VARIETY OF. NEEDS
UGH UGH UGH ARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS- WHO- IN A TIME OF.
A COLD SNAP OR- EXTREME. HEAT
NEED A PLACE TO GO TO- BUT ALSO
TO PROVIDE THE- OF FACILITIES
SO- FOR FIRES WHEREVER THEY
MIGHT OCCUR IN THE STATE WE
KNOW THAT OUR- FIRE SEASON IS
EXTENDED NOW NEARLY- A TWO YEAR
ROUND. AND THAT THESE
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO GET
MORE AND MORE USE SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CATCH UP
ON. OF SOME OF THE MAINTENANCE
THE TO FOR THAT'S DEFERRED FOR
A CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE DON'T OFTEN THINK OF AS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE YOU
KNOW NOT THAT THERE ARE
UNIMPORTANT BUT WE- WHEN IT
COMES TO FIRES WE TEND TO THINK
ABOUT. A FIRE EQUIPMENT TRUCKS
AND PERSONNEL AND THE LIKE- SO
I'D LIKE TO SEE IF WE CAN GET A
LITTLE MORE HEAD OF THIS ISSUE
AND APPRECIATED IF YOU'LL
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION. NOW
WE CERTAINLY WILL DETERMINE
BLOOMIN WE ACTUALLY ARE VERY
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SUPPORT YOU SHOW YOUR TODAY ND
HAVE SHOWN IN THE PAST FOR
THIS. WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO COME
UP WITH THE LIST THAT INFORMS
YOUR DECISION MAKING. GREAT
THANK YOU- LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE TO DID YOU
HAVE A I'M SORRY. YOU WERE
GOING FOR YOU MICHAEL PLEASE MR
BETHLEHEM TO ECHO YOUR COMMENTS
I THOUGHT THAT. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU- POINTING THAT
OUT I THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF
COMMON SENSE THANK YOU. ISSUE
NUMBER NINE IS THE STATE WATER
EFFICIENCY AND ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAMS. AND IT'S OUR LAST
ISSUE OF THE DAY. YES GOOD
MORNING- SO JENNY LESTER
MOFFETT AGAIN UNDER SECRETARY
AT. HI I'M THIS LAST ISSUE IS
THE STATE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM KNOWN AS WE-
IT WAS CREATED TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS.
TRANSACTION IRRIGATION SYSTEMS
THE THINK WATER AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE STATE
HAS INVESTED EIGHTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IN THIS WEEK
PROGRAMS. AND CDFA HAS MADE
GRANT AWARDS TO EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT PROJECTS HARPER
HOLDS A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND ACRES. IT HAS BEEN ONE
OF OUR MOST ON OVERSUBSCRIBED
PROGRAMS FOR THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS WITH AN OVER SUBSCRIPTION
RATE OF THREE HUNDRED PERCENT.
AND ITS LEVERAGE OVER FIFTY
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
MATCHING FUNDS. WE ESTIMATE
THAT SWEEP HAS RESULTED IN
EIGHTY THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF
CO TWO REDUCTIONS AT THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION
GALLONS OF WATER STATE ANNUALLY.
ADFA IS REQUESTING TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AS
WELL AS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR NEXT YEAR I FIND IT
DEPOSITIONAL PROJECTS UNDER
THIS HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL GRANT
PROGRAM. BY THINKING CURRENT
YEAR FUNDING WE CAN FUND
PROJECTS AND MORE WORK ON THE
GROUND AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE
ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE IN ANOTHER
EXTREMELY DRY YEAR. THE
QUESTION WAS RAISED BY THE LA-
ABOUT THE NEED FOR EARLY ACTION
ON THIS. EARLY ACTION FUNDING
ALLOWS US TO GET CONTRACTS
AWARDED EARLY. TO START WATER
SAVINGS EARLIER AND GET
PROJECTS ON THE GROUND EARLIER.
IF WE GET FUNDING AS SOON AS
AVAILABLE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
PUT OUT. THE REQUEST FOR GRANT
PROPOSALS AND AWARD THOSE
CONTRACTS THAT WE CAN GET DONE.
PROJECT ON IN THIS CALENDAR
YEAR AS OPPOSED TO WAITING FOR
NEXT YEAR TO PUT SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS IN THE GROUND. AND
IMPLEMENT THE WATER AND ENERGY
SAVINGS. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
REPORT QUESTIONS MISTER BENNETT.
THANK YOU I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS
ONE OF I APPRECIATE SWEET
PROGRAM THINK IT MAKES IT A LOT
OF COMMERCENTRE. YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE GROWING NUMBER OF
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS ARE BEING SUBMITTED-
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE MORE
THOSE AGENCIES LOOKING TO TRY
TO. GENERATE NEW WATER GENERATE
NEW APPROACHES WELL THESE ARE
THESE FUNDS DEDICATED TO
FARMING OPERATIONS OR A SOLE
PROPRIETOR OPERATIONS ONLY OR
WILL GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES ALSO BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR SWEET. FUNDED APPLICANTS
FOR THREE FUNDING ARE
TRADITIONALLY I'M JUST FOR A
FARMING OPERATIONS WORK AND
COMPANIES THAT ARE INSTALLING
DOES YOUR OCCASION SYSTEMS FOR
THE FARMING OPERATIONS- THERE
IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING I KNOW
THAT- IS IN THE D. W. R. BUDGET
FOR STATE MY IMPLEMENTATION AS
WELL. GREAT THANK YOU AND MY
OTHER QUESTION I THINK PROBABLY
IS FOR COMMITTEE STAFF- WAR.
FOR THE CHAIRMAN OR WHATEVER
BUT JUST AS I WAS THAT BECAUSE
I KNEW AND I SAY READ THE
SOMETIMES I READ. AT THE
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME FUNDING
OTHER TIMES IT'S A REQUEST FOR
GENERAL FUND. TO IS IT M. I.
ACCURATE AND ASSUMING THAT IF
IT SIMPLY SAYS GENERAL FUNDS AT
ITS REQUEST FOR GENERAL FUND ON
GOING. OR IS SURVIVED BY SHE A
SHAKE OF THE HEAD NOT SO IT'S
NOT ON CHOI IT'S A ONE TIME. SO
SOMETIMES IT SAYS ONE TIME AND
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T WHAT
SHOULD IS THERE A DISTINCTION
WHEN I READ A REPORT. MY
AMBITION OKAY SO. ALL OF US
OTHERWISE INDICATED ESTIMATES
ONE TIME OKAY SO ALSO IT LESS
AND LESS INDICATED ONGOING SAYS
SET SOMETHING LIKE ON GOING AND
IT'S JUST ONE TYPE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR. LOOK THERMISTORS
MATTER JUST IF I HEARD RIGHT
YOU SAID TO THE NEED IS 3100%
OVER. THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
CORRECT THAT IS THE OVER
SUBSCRIPTION RATE FOR THAT
SWEET PROGRAM AND OVERALL FOR
THAT PASSED. I'M A HAVE TO
FLOWS OF COURSE BACK ON FOR THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS AND SO THIS
WOULD BE ANOTHER IDEAL PROGRAM
JUST LIKE THE LAST ONE WITH
AFFAIRS. YOU'RE DOING SUCH A
GREAT JOB THE NEED IS OUT THERE
IF YOU WERE ABLE TO HAVE. SOME
OF THE WINDFALL MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THIS YEAR. THAT HE
WOULD PUT IT TO WORK ALMOST
RIGHT AWAY. YEAH OKAY WILL TRY
TO. A PUBLIC PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO DO AND THAT'S
ALWAYS WITH ANY GRANT PROGRAMS
YEAH JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
TRYING TO HELP THAT OUT. THANK
YOU. MS RIVER. HEY I'M IT UP
THE REPORT INDICATES THAT FIVE
PERCENT- OF THESE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHERE SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- ARE PRIORITIZED- DO
WE KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE OF FARMS
RECEIVE THE GRANT. IN THE. I DO
NOT HAVE THE TOP AT THE TOP OF
MY FINGERTIPS BUT I'M GONNA
PASS IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUE I'M
DOCTOR ARE RECOGNIZED AS THE
CAR AT HIS. BACK RUSSIAN. GOOD
MORNING JAM CHAT AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK VERY WELL THANK. YEAH I'M A
GUNASEKARA SCENTED BEST
SECRETARY AND MANAGER THAT
WOULD BE PROGRAMS- THANK YOU
JENNIFER THAT QUESTION AND
MEMBER FOR THE QUESTION THE 25%
OF OUR FANS HAVE TO GO TO
PROJECTS IN THOSE REGIONS.
INSTRUCTED HOW. TWENTY LET ME
REPEAT 25% OFF THE GROUND TO
COAT BENEFITS. AFTER THAT I CAN
BELIEVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO TO
DISADVANTAGED FAMILIES AND
RANCHERS. OKAY SO THAT'S
ALREADY BUILT INTO THE GRANT
PROGRAM RIGHT. 25% IS ALLOCATED
FOR THESE- DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS CHARACTER. THAT'S RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S
HEAR FROM A LA- AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'M FRANK MENACE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE FIND THAT THE SWEET
PROPOSAL ALIGNS WITH PATH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES- SUCH AS
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS AND-
SUSTAINABLY MANAGING WATER
RESOURCES. HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
THE PROPOSED FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR I'M TO MINIMIZE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY OF
AWARDING. THESE GRANTS IN TWO
CYCLES AND WHILE I WE AGREE
THAT FUNDING EARLY WE WOULD GET
PROJECTS OUT SOONER- BASED ON
DEPARTMENTS TIMELINE. I'M NOT
OF THE PROJECT WOULD BE AWARDED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR SO WE FELT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSITATE EARLY
ACTION. FINANCE. HELLO AGAIN IN
YOUR WHOLE WITH FINANCE- WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THAT THE
FUNDING BEING PROPOSED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR ALIGNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER EARLY
ACTION EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR AREAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC- WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT- THIS PROPOSAL AS PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS.
FOR EXPANDABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT IMPLEMENTATION.
WHICH IS ALSO INCLUDING FUNDING
FOR D. W. R. TO SUPPORT PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION- BECAUSE
SEGMENTS SUCH A LARGE ISSUE.
AND THE FACT THAT THESE
PARTICULAR FUNDS WILL BE USED
TO SUPPORT CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED GROUNDWATER BASINS. WE
FEEL THAT EARLY ACTION IS
WARRANTED HERE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS AND THAT'LL A CLOSE
OUT THIS ITEM WILL BE HOLDING
GO ALL OF OUR- DISCUSSION ITEMS
TODAY- THE ITEMS THAT WE
PURCHASED- WILL BE HOLDING OPEN
AND- WILL NOW HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC. LET ME REPEAT THAT- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CUT TO PROVIDE
YOUR COMMENTS WILL BE LIMITING
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THAT CODE. IS.
1-315-437-1315 FOUR. THREE
SEVEN IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM. OF
GETTING THROUGH PLEASE CALL THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AND IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO BE HEARD IN PUBLIC
COMMENT. NOPE AT THE END
ANYBODY SO- LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES. OPERATOR ARE YOU THERE.
I AM I RIGHT WE WILL OPEN THE
LINE FOR COMMENT FROM LINE
TWENTY ONE. YOU MAY GO AHEAD
THANK TWENTY ONE. THE NEW
SWITCHED THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS WHICH
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ITEM
FOURTEEN THE PROPOSED SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION TO CDFA FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND MICRO
GRANTS TO SMALL MID SIZED AND
UNDERSHIRT FARMERS. GIVEN THE
URGENT NEED TO HELP SMALL
FARMERS ACCESS FEDERAL PUBLIC
RELEASED WE ASK THAT YOU MOVE
QUICKLY TO APPROVE THE PROPOSED
THREE POINT THREE FIVE MILLION
PER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. CATEGORIES WITH DEFINING
SMALL FARM AS A HUNDRED ACRES
LAST ALSO SUPPORTS ITEM FIFTEEN
THE PROPOSED TRANSITION THE
SAFER SUSTAINABLE PAST
MANAGEMENT INCREASED TO THE
MAIL SHE IS OVERDUE BUT WE WANT
TO SEE DETAILED BUDGET LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE THE FUNDS GO TO
ESSENTIAL. PROGRAMS DESCRIBED
IN THE BE DEEPLY. THANK
RENEWING CEDIA BY. AND GREAT
FARMING SYSTEM AND I PRO.
CAPPED CONSIDER. A PER. HIGH
IMPACT PROGRAMS BOLSTERING UC
CSU IPM PROGRAM TO HELP GROWERS
IMPLEMENT SAFER ALTERNATIVES.
AND EXPANDING THE P. R. I. P.
M. RESEARCH GRANT AND BEST
PRACTICES. PROMOTION IT IS
IMPORTANT CAST MEMBERS THAT
FAMILY FARMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE BEST SCIENCE BASED
INFORMATION FINALLY. CAST JOINS
OUR COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSED. SWEET FUNDING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO
THANK YOU. NEXT QUESTION ARE
I'M SORRY OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE TWENTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS INGRID
BROSTROM OF THE SAN ANDREAS
POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT I
DON'T WANT WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING OF THE AEGIS MARGARET
PROGRAM- EDITH MIGRANT FUNDING
PORTENT AND INNOVATIVE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RELATIVELY
LITTLE CLASS. AND MUST BE FULLY
FUNDED WITH SECURE CONSISTENT
AND ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE I
THINK MAKING THE EASIEST
PROGRAM FUNDING CONDITIONAL
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE PERIOD. YOU
CAN TALK TO CONTRIBUTED SMALL
GRANTED EVEN MORE INAPPROPRIATE
ALKA IS OVERSUBSCRIBED AND DOES
NOT HAVE A SUFFICIENT NEXUS TO
THE Y. GREATER PROJECT ELIGIBLE
FOR. A GRANT AND I DON'T COURT
WE GENERALLY SUPPORT THE INFLUX
OF ADDITIONAL REMEDIATION PLAN
AND PLAN FOR PARKS ABOUT
HOWEVER THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FUNDING PROPOSAL NEEDS
TO BE MORE FULLY THAT IT. THERE
ARE SOME ACCOMMODATION
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW RENDON
MEDIATION WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND STATE LIABILITIES REGARDING
THE OIL AND GAS SECTOR.
LEADERSHIP MCCORMICK
DISCUSSIONS ON TOPICAL
MEDIATION WELL OVER MEDIATION
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION MAY BE
BETTER USED AS SEED FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA REMEDIATION
CORE. TO BUILD BETTER STRUCTURE
TO ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
REMEDIATION AND WORKFORCE
ISSUES WITH THE STATE FINALLY
ON ITEM THREE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
IN CONCEPT OF THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND AN
UPDATED STATE WHAT HAZARDOUS
WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN. HOWEVER
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
FUNDING TO UPDATE AND REBEKAH
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM
WHICH IS GOING TO BE INTEGRAL
TO ANY DETECTED REFORM EFFORT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO A MORE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
ADMINISTRATION 12-1 TO GET THE
PICTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND OUR NEXT COMIC COMES FROM
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX. POINT
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUSTIN RATHER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM THE STATE WIDE
MULTI INTEREST COALITION OF
MORE THAN A HUNDRED NINETY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT STATEWIDE.
TO FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFT THE WAY
THAT THE SIDES ARE USED IN
CALIFORNIA. OR HAVE BEEN HAVE
SIGNED ON TO ACOALITION
LETTER. BEING CIRCULATED WITH
YOUR STAFF REGARDING THE
PROPOSED HERE TO MALES FEE
ISSUE FIVE- CPR WITHOUT THE
ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE. ALLOCATE PORTIONS OF
THE- IF THE REVENUE TO
COMMUNITY PROTECTIONS
STRENGTHENED AIR MONITORING.
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION AND
SUPPORT FOR FARMERS TO
TRANSITION TO SUSTAINABLE
ALTERNATIVES. YOU LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT ON THE
ISSUE WITH YOU AS WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
NINE LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR BLOOM AND THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ON FAIRGROUNDS
OPERATION SUPPORT. AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE
SEVEN ZERO ISSUE EIGHT. MY NAME
IS BECKY BARTLING I'M THE CEO
OF THE CINEMA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
NETWORK AFFAIRS. AT THE COUNTY
FAIR WHO IS STILL SUPPORTING
SOLELY FOR THE ANNUAL FAIR AND
IN TERMS OF THEM. AT A
FAIRGROUND THAT HAS SUPPORTED
FOR FIRE EVACUATION ONE FLOOD
EVACUATION IN JUST THE PAST
FIVE YEARS AND HAVE BEEN
HOUSING CO THE TESTING COVERED
VACCINATION AND HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS AT RISK FOR COVERT
NINETEEN. I ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT IN MAKING THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO ALL IN THE
CALIFORNIA NETWORK AFFAIRS. AS
WE HAVE ALL BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED FINANCIALLY BY THE
CANCELLATION OF OUR FAIR CITY
INTERMENT DANCE DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA FAIRS
ANSWER THE CALL TO OPEN HELPS
PEOPLE ANIMALS AND THOUSANDS OF
STATE HEALTHCARE TEAMS DURING
WILDFIRES AND. OTHER EMERGENCY
EVACUATION. THE FUNDING WILL GO
A LONG WAY SUPPORT THESE
EFFORTS AS WELL PROVIDE NEEDED
FUNDING FOR OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL
SUPPORT EMERGENCY EVACUATION.
AND HELP ALL CALIFORNIA FAIR
STAY VIABLE AS COUNTY AND STATE
ASSETS AND I THINK YOU CHAIR
BLOOM FOR YOUR- GREAT INTEREST
IN HELPING FARES MECCA BURKE
MAINTENANCE. AND THEIR NEEDS
FOR THESE EVACUATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE TWENTY THREE LINE
TWENTY THREE YEAR LINE TO OPEN.
THE MORNING THANK YOU CHAIR
BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOE FUNDING I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK. I'M HERE TODAY TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT FUNDING FROM THE
STATE FOR THE PAST THREE
FUNDING CYCLES TO THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK. AND ALLOW THIS NOT
ONLY HELPS SMALL BUSINESSES
OPERATE MORE SUSTAINABLY BUT TO
HELP THEM BUILD RESILIENCE. WE
HAVE PROVIDED BY LOCAL BIT
RELIEF OUTREACH TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. ASSISTING THEM WITH
EVERYTHING COVERED BUSINESS
BASICALLY TO PUTTING THEM IN
TOUCH WITH THE MANY GRANT FROM-
AND ALSO HELPING WITH A FOR
DISINFECTION. REALLY THE STATE
IN THE NATION OF WORKING HARD
TO REACH BUSINESS. TO CREATE A
VIBRANT GREEN ECONOMY OFTEN
WORKING IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WELL OUR LONG TERM
GOAL IS TO COVER THE ENTIRE
STATE CERTIFIED FORTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES. ARE MORE MEDIA GOAL
IS TO CREATE A NEW NORMAL WEAR
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES GAIN THE
GREEN BUSINESS ADVANTAGE TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC. AND
CONSUMERS ARE GUIDED TO VOTE
WITH THEIR DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE MORE
SUSTAINABLY. NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO PULL THE PLUG ON OUR
PROGRAMS TO HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE BUSINESS SAID. WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL INITIATIVES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR
SUPPORTING OUR GREEN BUSINESS
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT BOTH OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR ECONOMY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
NINETEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF
THIS COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN
CALLING TODAY ON TWO ISSUES
FIRST ON ISSUE FIVE DEALING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE
REGULATION OUR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS AND THE WESTERN PART
HEALTH ASSOCIATION. ARE OPPOSED
TO THE PROPOSED TIERED
ASSESSMENT I WE ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL
DEPTHS TO THE DEPARTMENT
AFFECT. STATE REGULATION I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE APPROACH
PRESENTED IN THE RIGHT ONE
TODAY IT WOULD PROVIDE FOR A
40% INCREASE IN MORE THAN FORTY
STAFF I ADDED DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAS ALREADY SEEN A 15% BUDGET
INCREASE OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS NOTWITHSTANDING THE FACT
THAT THE BILL HAS REMAINED. AT
A STATIC CONDITION IT ADJUSTS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS BASED ON
SALES AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUE GOING
FORWARD. SECOND ISSUE ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION A
CALL IN SUPPORT OF THE ISSUE
ITEM EIGHT HOW WE DO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S APPROPRIATION
FOR FARES BUT DO WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THAT BE MADE.
AVAILABLE TO ALL PLAYERS
INCLUDING CHARACTERS OUT
WRITTEN IT IS IN VIOLATION OF
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
ONE NINE SIX TWO ZERO I WHICH
STATE THAT MONEY FOR OPERATIONS
WOULD BE- SEGREGATED BASED ON
GOVERNANCE OF A FAIRGROUND. WE
DON'T BELIEVE WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
INVENTORIES OF THE STATE
FAIRGROUNDS TO DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT JOURNAL SERVICES TO
BE FOR A PROPERTY THREE MILLION
FOR THAT PURPOSE LIKE TO
COORDINATE WITH THE GST SEE
WHAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE AND
FINALLY SUPPORT YOUR A
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD FOR.
A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS
FOR THESE FAIR GROUNDS AROUND
THE STATE I LOOK FORWARD. TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THOSE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM A
LINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN REGARDING
MEDIA PHASE AND REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE ALONG WITH ISSUE
NUMBER NINE INCLUDING EARLY
ACTION TO FUND THE WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT THE KNACK TO HELP.
IMPLEMENT WATER USE EFFICIENCY
DURING DROUGHT YEARS. AND WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
REGARDING GPS GPRS MIL PROPOSAL
THIS CHANGE REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT POLICY AND
FINANCIAL SHIFT IN THE PROGRAM.
FARMERS PURPOSELY AVOID USING
HIGHER TOXICITY PRODUCT BUT
WHERE IT'S UNAVOIDABLE GIVEN
TEST PRESSURES INFESTATION.
THEY'RE LEFT WITH NO
APPLICATION OPTION WELL THE
PROPOSAL INTENSIFIED THE MARKET
SIGNALED WELL CONCERNED THAT IT
WILL PERPETUATE A MARKET
FAILURE I'M NOT RECOGNIZING ON
FARM REALITIES AND SMALL
FARMERS ARE INHERENTLY PRICE
TAKERS AND THAT'S THE FACT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD BATTLE. ARE
SMALL AND MIDSIZED FARMS
INCLUDING ORGANIC PRODUCERS
STRUGGLING WITH INCREDIBLE
OFFER THROUGH KOBE WITH EVEN
HIGHER UNAVOIDABLE PRODUCTION
COSTS SO WE ASK THAT COMMITTEE
TO RECONSIDER THAT ALONG WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE'RE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A FROM LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JULIE JORDAN LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. I THINK YOU
FIVE WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO THE
STATE SUPPORT FOR TRANSITION
AWAY FROM HARMFUL PESTICIDES
AND TOWARDS REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE TO THE PROPOSED. WE
SUPPORT THE USE OF THESE FUNDS
FOR STRENGTHENED ENFORCEMENT
THEY'RE MONITORING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND TRANSITIONING
FARMERS TOWARDS PRACTICES THAT
PROTECT PEOPLE AND BIODIVERSITY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO APPROVE A
MILKY THAT MEANINGFULLY
INCLUDES DIRECT COMMUNITY
PROTECTION. REQUIRED TO
MITIGATE EXPOSURE FOR THOSE
MOST IMPACTED BY PESTICIDES AT
HOME SCHOOL AND WORK FOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS IS
LONG OVERDUE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE LIVING WITH CANCER
RESPIRATORY DISEASES AND OTHER
CONDITIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
CHEMICALLY DEPENDENT
AGRICULTURE SYSTEM THAT TRIED.
TO BE EXPENSIVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
LASTLY ON ISSUED THE D. TO CVV
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT FOR THE AND
THEN BY THING. AND THE STATE
HAS WITH MEDICATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT PER LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MAN
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LAURIE KING AND THE
DEPUTY MANAGER AT THE BIG
FRESNO FAIR AND FRESNO COUNTY
I'M CALLING REGARDING THE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY UNDER THE
CDFA CDFA ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA FAIRS.
THE SEVENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
FAIR TO THE LIFELINE OF EACH
COMMUNITY IN OUR GREAT STATE
AND OUR FAIRGROUNDS SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE RESIDED. AT
THE BIG FRESNO FAIR WE'VE
OPENED OUR DOORS TO WILDFIRE
EVACUATIONS INCLUDING THE
DEVASTATING CREEK FIRE THIS
YEAR SERVICE TO DISTRIBUTE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS AND WORKED
THROUGH COVER TESTING AND NOW
COVER VACCINATIONS AS MANY
FARES IN OUR STATE HAVE DONE.
EVERY FIRE FARING CALIFORNIA IS
STRUGGLING TRYING TO CREATE
REVENUE AND FOLLOW ALL STATE
GUIDELINES WE'VE ALL LOST DEATH
AND ARE THE PRIME EXAMPLE OF
TRYING TO DO MORE WITH LESS. WE
ALL NEED ASSISTANCE AND IF WE
HAVE ANY CHANCE TO SURVIVE I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF MAKING THE
MONEY AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA AFFAIRS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE PLEASE HELP SAVE OUR
CALIFORNIA FAIRS BY INCLUDING
FUNDING WHEN. YOU VOTE FOR THIS
MISSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A QUESTION- I'M SORRY A
COMMENT PER LINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS GAIL
DELLA HANDS WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION TO ISSUE FIVE. AND
PRETTY MUCH FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY MENTIONED BY OTHER
AGRICULTURAL ORGANIZATION. WE
DO BELIEVE THAT- BE DEFICIT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS- IN THIS
MANNER. AT THIS TIME AND WE
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO- COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON THAT. WE ALSO
SUPPORT- S. ISSUED NINE THIS
WEEK FUNDING OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS WATER USE
EFFICIENCY THE NEAR CATION. AND
HELP ADDRESS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SCOTT DID THESE
MONIES WILL ALSO HELP TO
ADDRESS THE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED- GROUNDWATER BASIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT QUESTION I
WILL BE OF- ARE A PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE FORTY TWO THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR COMMENT. REBECCA
MARKETS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST IN THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK. IN SUPPORT
OF SEVERAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE
PROPOSAL TO UPDATE AND HERE THE
NEXT TO HAVE TO FIGHT **** IN
ADDITION TO OUR SUPPORT RIVER
WE REQUEST SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET TO DIRECT FUNDS TO
PROGRAMS TO HELP FARMERS MANAGE
PASSED A SLATE. AND ISSUE
NUMBER NINE FORTY MILLION FOR
THE SWEET PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
A. F. T. REQUEST TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION TO GO TO CDFA TO
ADMINISTER GRANT PROGRAMS.
FUNDING TECHNICAL ADVISERS TO
ASSIST LANDOWNERS AND
DEVELOPING MANAGEMENT PLANS.
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS TO THE AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTY DUE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGLAS. AND
FINALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERFACE THE STATE OF OPEN
COLLABORATIVE AND INNOVATIVE
HEALTH SOLUTIONS WE REQUEST
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR AN
EXPANSION OF THE SENIOR FARMERS
MARKET NUTRITION PROGRAM.
ADMINISTERED AT UTSA THE FUNDS
REQUESTED WHICH FEET IN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND SENIORS AND FIVE
MILLION TO LAUNCH A FARM FRESH
TO SENIORS PROGRAM CDFA IT'S
FARM TO FORK OFFICE. TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO PROVIDE
LOCAL HEALTHY FOOD TO OLDER
ADULTS IN CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS MODELED AFTER THE FARM.
TO SCHOOL PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CALLING TO SPEAK
ON THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT. MY NAME IS BECKY
BAILEY FINDLEY AND I REPRESENT
WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA TEARS ALLIANCE.
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPROPRIATION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE- CARE
NETWORK WITH ONE SUBJECT TO
CHANGE AND THAT IS THAT THE
FUNDING BE AVAILABLE TO THE
ENTIRE NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRS. HISTORICALLY
APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE STATE
FOR OPERATIONAL NEEDS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO ALL PLAYERS REGARDLESS
OF THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
AND IN THE FACE OF CRISIS OR
EMERGENCY. OFF THEIR GROUND I
POTENTIALLY ACTIVATED THOSE WHO
ARE IN CRISIS DON'T WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER IT IS A COUNTY FAIR AND
NONPROFIT THEIR ESTATE RELATED
CARE OR EVEN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FAIR. THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUT. VENDORS THAT PROVIDE
COMMUNITY BUILDING EDUCATION
AND ACCESS TO HEALTHY LIVING
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND OUR
SOURCES PER SAVE AMERICAN TV
SPOTS FOR PEOPLE AND FOR
ANIMALS OFFICERS HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD BY PANDEMIC LOCKDOWN AND
ALL NEED ASSISTANCE WITH
OPERATIONAL NEEDS AN IMMEDIATE
OVERWHELMING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. THIS GIVES
THEM A CHANCE TO SURVIVE AND TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN A SAFE MANNER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
THE LAN LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN WORLD
COUNTY I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON THREE IF YOU CAN BE
SUPER QUICK THE FIRST IS BOTH
ONLY ISSUE THREE. POWER CYCLE
BEVERAGE OUR PILOT PROJECT WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THE WAY TO
INCREASE CONSUMER ACT THAT
COULD IMPROPER KIND OF THE
PERFECT PLACE IN BERLIN
UNSERED AREAS. WHEN OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE GOT THE
NUMBER OF OTHER MINOR STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT WOULD HELP US TO
ACHIEVE THAT OBJECTIVE. I'M
VOTE ONLY FOR OUR TYPE OF
ORGANIC WASTES PERFECT WHEN
EMPLOYMENT PATIENT THINKING. WE
REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL
AND WHAT THE COMMITTED TO
DELAYED SHIPPING SEVERAL THAT
THE PERSONNEL FROM TECHNICAL.
PROGRAM TO ENFORCEMENT THE
REGULATIONS WERE ADOPTED THREE
MONTHS AGO AND WE HAVE TO PAY
MORE MONEY AVAILABLE PROGRAMS
TO IMPLEMENT THESE
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGES SO WE
URGE TO LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE.
FOR YOU KNOW AT LEAST ANOTHER
YEAR TO GO AND THEN FINALLY I
CAN BE HEARD NUMBER THREE HE
KEPT THESE GOVERNMENT. REFORM
WE SHARE THE OVER ARCHING GOAL
OF IMPROVING GOVERNANCE THE
CROWDING PTSD WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. EFFECTIVELY TO THE
EXTENT THEY ADDRESS WORK ON AND
THE LACK OF THE CONTAMINATED
BY. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
EVALUATE THE PROPOSAL THAT'S
JUST BEEN RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC BUT THAT JUST APPLY GOOD
WE HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS THE
PLASTER PROPOSAL WITH THAT
DENTAL IMPACT SIXTY INCREASES
AND SPECIALLY BIG PENSION
REPEAL. MAY HAVE ON THE ABILITY
FOR SMALLER LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
CONTINUE OPERATING HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES AND USED
OIL COLLECTION PROGRAMS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
TODAY. LOOK FOR THE WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM ONE NUMBER FOR
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NUMBER FOR FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MR CARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DAN. I'M TO CEO THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY FAIR AND I'M
ALSO THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFFAIRS ALLIANCE I
AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT AND THE
SUPPORT OF ALL SEVENTY SEVEN
FARES IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PROPOSED BUDGET REGARDING
FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT WE ARE ASKING THAT ALL
SEVENTY SEVEN FARES IN THE
NETWORK AND NOT JUST STATE
AFFILIATED FAIRS BE INCLUDED.
ALL FARES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC IN FARES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE OWNERSHIP HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS NOT ONLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC BUT THE DIRT BUT
DURING OTHER EMERGENCIES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. FAIR THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAS STAYED TOGETHER
SERVING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THE STATE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE THEREFORE
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO STAND BEHIND
ALL FARES AS THEY ATTEMPT TO
RECOVER FROM THIS UNPRECEDENTED
PANDEMIC IN CLOSURE OF
FAIRGROUNDS ACTIVITIES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THAT FLIGHT NUMBER FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING DON CAP T.
WITH MCCUE CAPTAIN THE FIFTY
AT. FIRST WITH REGARDS TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE RELATED TO THE
PROPOSED DEEP YARD CELL TAX
PROPOSAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. AND
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA C. AND J. ENERGY I.
T. TEAM UP TODAY CONCERNS ABOUT
YOUR BILL PACKED APPROACHES
THAT BUILD TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
FIFTEEN ABILITY EFFORTS ALREADY
UNDERWAY. BY MANUFACTURERS OF
DISINFECTANTS ANTI MICROBIAL
PESTICIDES AND AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS INCLUDING
CONCENTRATION OF PRODUCTS
REDUCE AMOUNTS NEEDED FOR
INTENDED PURPOSE. WATER USAGE
REDUCTION IN PACKAGING NEEDED
ADDED TURN. GREENHOUSE GASES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRANSPORTING
SUCH PRODUCTS THE NGA AND GI
FIFTEEN BELIEVE THAT YOUR
APPROACH COULD SERVE AS A
DISINCENTIVE TO CONTINUE THE
SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS. AND
COULD RESULT IN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES NEVERTHELESS THE
MTA AND SEE I THINK YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE ON THIS
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
RESEARCH NEEDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. WITH REGARD TO
NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER ONE RELATED
TO THE SMALL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GRANT PROGRAM ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE WITH UP TO DATE
CONCERNS WITH THE USE OF THE
TOP TECH COUNT GIVEN ITS
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. STARTLING
THE ACCOUNT WITH ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES THAT THIS TIME IS
CONCERNING AND PROBLEMATIC
FINALLY ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION BONTA GST AN
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL FOR
GOVERNANCE OF FISCAL REFORM
RELATED TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
AT THE LEGISLATURE WILL RECALL
FEED WITH PLEASED TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THE LAST SESSION ON ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE NINE FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES AND EVEN
SUPPORTED THE MEASURE WHICH
ALSO INCLUDED FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE TALK CONSTRUCTION
DOT NET. HOWEVER GIVEN THE
RECENT RELEASE JUST WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- WHICH WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING I WILL DEFER COMMENT
ON THAT. AT THIS POINT BUT WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ON THE PROPOSAL
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. DGFT
ALLEGES H. R. THANK YOU. THANK
WE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
NUMBERS ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINES ONE TO LINE IS OPEN. I
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF I'M
DANIEL CAN CAMP THE CALIPH. IF
YOU TO FOR BEAUTIFUL THAT. I
WANTED TO SEE I. D. SUPPORT
ISSUE BY HUNDRED TO STAY
THURSDAY PASSED. IT'S A LONG
OVERDUE TO THE MULTI THE
PROPOSAL ALSO KEEPS IT A
FEELING NOT ATTACK AND IT'S
REALLY IMPROVED THE- WITH A
YOUR ADDRESSES THE DIFFERENT
BURDEN POSED THE WORKING. THOSE
ARE ONES THAT ARE BY LAW THE
LABELED WAR DAY IN POINT THAT.
AS YOU MOVE WITH THIS THE
CONSIDER LANGUAGE THAT
TYPICALLY DIRECTS. TO INTENDED.
INCLUDING PESTICIDE RELIEF FUND
FOR COMMUNITIES AND FARMWORKERS
AIR MONITORING TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. FUNDING TO HELP
FARMERS AND WORKERS SHE'S
WORKERS MANAGE PASSED AND
ESPECIALLY FOR ECOSYSTEM. AND
BIODIVERSITY MONITORING. TODAY
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL SEEING AN
ACROSS THE BOARD FACT
APOCALYPSE WITH THE- OF MONARCH.
IN POLLINATOR LOSSES. THAT THE
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER YOUR FUNDING.
THANK YOU CONSIDER YOUR ONE
FUNDING TOWARD COMPLETING A
BASELINE INSECT BIODIVERSITY
SURVEY. SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND FIND
PRAGMATIC SOLUTIONS. AND WE
ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
OUR PARTNERS COMMENTS THANK YOU
ADVANCED DIRECT COMMUNITY
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO MITIGATE EXPOSURE FOR
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE AND HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY PESTICIDES IN
PARTICULAR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. OF COLOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FORTY SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CARLENE MOORE AND I'M THE CEO
OF THE TWENTY SECOND DISTRICT
AGASSI ASIAN THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS HOME OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FAIR. AND I'M
COMMENTING ON ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY ISSUE EIGHT FOR
FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. ON
BEHALF OF MY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PREPARATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE FAIR NETWORK
WITH TO CAVIAR. THE FIRST THAT
NEXT YEAR OF MONEY A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT AND TEN MILLION IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
ENTIRE NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS AT ALL THIRDS IN
THE NETWORK HAVE BEEN HIT HARD
BY COBIT. NEITHER SIDE NOR
GOVERNANCE MODEL DETERMINES
SAYS IMPACT. SECONDLY THAT THE
BALANCE OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR FUNDS BE MADE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY TO SUPPORT
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES. TO BOTH
THE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
FINANCIALLY FOLLOWING LAYOFFS
AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH TO THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE. FOR SOME REDUCTIONS IN
STAFF AS WELL AS OPERATIONAL
EXPENSES TO A BARE MINMUM HAVE
SIMPLY NOT BEEN ENOUGH TO
OVERCOME THE NEGATIVE FINANCIAL
IMPACTS RESULTING FROM THIS
PANDEMIC. AS RECENT HISTORY HAS
SHOWN US CALIFORNIA'S ENTIRE
NETWORK OF FAIRGROUNDS ARE
VITAL TO THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLANS AND THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS NO EXCEPTION. HERE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY ARE
PARAGONS OF HOSTED MULTIPLE
WILDFIRE EVACUATIONS COBIT
NINETEEN TESTING FOOD
DISTRIBUTION AND CURRENTLY A
VACCINATION SUPERSTATION. WE'D
LIKE ALL FAIRGROUNDS ARE
INDISPENSABLE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND SURVIVAL OF ALL
FAIR GROUNDS IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE STATE'S OVERALL RECOVERY
PLAN. VERY IMMEDIATE AND FUTURE
OPERATIONAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS IF
THE NETWORK HAS ANY CHANCE OF
SURVIVING SO PLEASE MAKE
CERTAIN ALL FAIR GROUNDS HAVE
THAT CHANCE WHEN YOU VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE INCLUDING CURRENT
SURVIVAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF CALLER
STILL ON THE LINE AND THE ONLY
ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES LEFT- TO
WRAP UP BY THE FIRE APPOINTED
HOUR I'M SO I'M GONNA ASK- EACH
OF YOU TO PLEASE HOLD YOUR
COMMENTS REMAINING SPEAKERS TO
HOLD YOUR COMMENTS. TO- ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
THIRTEEN THAT'S LINE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE HOUSEHOLD
AND COMMERCIAL PRODUCT THAT THE
STATION I AM PROVIDING COMMENTS
ON ISSUED BY. OUR THANK YOU CAN
REPRESENTS A VARIETY OF
MANUFACTURERS TO PRODUCE NON
ACT PACIFIED LIKE DISINFECTANT
WHICH ACCOUNT 450% OF THE
REVENUE COLLECTED BY DPRK
DEVELOPMENT. WELL WE DON'T
SEVERAL CONCERNS THAT THE PDP
AND ENTER THE TIME I'LL JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS- PREVIOUSLY
REYES AND JUST NOTE THAT WHILE
THE MAIL I HAD NOT BEEN RAISED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR. THE
REVENUE COLLECTED VIA THE MAIL
HAS INCREASED BY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS SPENT THAT TIME. BY
BEATING THE FEE ON EVERY DOLLAR
SOLD THE AMOUNT COLLECTED BY
THE TAX DEPARTMENT DOES
INCREASE. ACROSS THE PESTICIDES
INCREASE. AT ALL NOTE- THE AS
NINETEEN IN HERE BEFORE THAT.
BEGINNING A RIGHT. PER TO
INCREASE REGISTRATION FEES. AND
EITHER PAID BY THE SAME
MANUFACTURER TO PAY NO TAX SO
WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THAT WHEN DELIBERATING
THE AMOUNT OF THE NO INCREASE.
AND LASTLY I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THE DEPARTMENT'S
REVENUE SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. AS WE EXPECT
THERE TO BE A NOTABLE INCREASE
DEFINED IN LARGE PART AS A
RESULT OF THE INCREASE FAILED
TO DIFFERENT TACK IN HIS
INCREASE WOULD GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE IN A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS. AND TO DEVELOP THE
SOLUTION APPOINT ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND. THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN BERMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WE WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER COMMENT THE RESPECTING
AFFECT ON IT TO BE A DATA. ONE
ITEM FOR IMPLEMENTING ORGANIC
WASTE REQUIREMENTS SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC OF CYCLING
MANIC MANDATES ARE COMPLICATED
AND CHALLENGING BUT I LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO WORK YOU CAN
MEET THIS MANDATE. WITH THE
REGULATION COMING OUT OF YOUR
LATE WE THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME SENSIBLE THOUGHT THAT CAN
BE TAKEN TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL
HOWEVER MOVING STOCKTON LOCAL
SYSTEMS HELP FRANKLIN FUSION TO
ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE. MAY NOT
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL THIS REPORT
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
ON THE ISSUE. SECOND QUICK
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PILOT PROGRAM IS THAT GENERALLY
SUPPORT A NATIONAL PILOT
PROGRAMS TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND COMMUNITIES
ACHIEVE A WORKABLE PROGRAM
HOWEVER THE NEED FOR PROGRAM A
PLAN IS NOT IN THREE TO FIVE
YEARS AS A BEACHY DENNIS
PROGRAM BUT NOW. WE AFTER THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE JOHN
KENNEDY FROM THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND RECOMMEND IMMEDIATE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM AT THE MINUTE IN OUR
COALITION LETTER. FINALLY FOR
AFFAIRS AND FAIRS FAIRGROUND.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WHAT THE
CONTINUED AFTER TO SHOW UP
FUNDING FOR. FAIR THESE FARES
PROVIDE CRITICAL THOUGHT NUMBER.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE. THIRD BROWN
NOT ONLY STATE FOR PEOPLE LIVE
FAR AND CHáVEZ. THEY ARE STILL
GROUND FOR A LARGE OP. WORKING
STATE SUPPORT FOR IS CRITICAL
FACILITIES. FOR MAINTENANCE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIX ZERO. HELLO BUT
DENNIS BELL B. THE ON THE TO
CALIFORNIA DURING FETUSES
BECAUSE- PIZZA KITCHEN. COMPANY
SEVERAL OTHER AYE AGAIN COULD.
I WE'RE ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I
DO WANT RECOGNIZE. THAT- AND
COMPLEMENT THE SOME OF THE
BENETTON HIS. RECOGNITION OF
LA- COMMENTS ON THE TIERED
APPROACH AND THAT THERE ARE
SOME. CHALLENGES THERE EVEN IF
THEY WERE TO DO THIS HOW WOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED OTHER BETTER
WAYS I THINK THIS IS SHOWS THAT
THIS. PROPOSAL IS NOT FULLY
VETTED IN FULLY COOKED AND I
NEED TO BE PUT. ON THE SIDE
AGAIN MIKE FOLKS ARE INTERESTED
IN TRYING TO. MEET THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT OF DPR AND
WILLING TO HELP HAVE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD. LIKE
TO GO BACK UP ITEM FOR IN. THE
NON VOTE. AREAS ON ORGANIC WAY.
THIS IS FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION PACIFIC COAST
RENDERING THIRTY. AS WELL- THE
DARK OU CORPORATE IN THAT WE
HAVE TO. OF SHIPPING EXAM WHERE
WITH THE LOWER GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT THAT SHOULD BE NOT MANY
FOLKS OVER- THIS QUICKLY WHEN
WE'RE STILL IN ADMINISTERING%
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. THE
DEPUTIES HAVE BEEN RECYCLING
ORGANICS FOR YEARS I NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE TO THE MARKETS TO WHICH
THEY SERVED THREE YEARS-
WITHOUT WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. WEHAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX
THREE. HI I'M JAN DIETRICH WITH
THE DETROIT INSTITUTE FOR
APPLIED INSECT ECOLOGY SPEAKING
ABOUT ISSUE FIVE ABOUT
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT.
THERE'S TOO MUCH UNNECESSARY
USE OF DANGEROUS PESTICIDES
PEOPLE COULD BE HARMED WE
WELCOME THE GOVERNOR'S VISION.
IMPLEMENT THIS IN ONE YEAR AND
LOOK OUT THE L. A- SUGGESTION
TO TIDE TEARING TO CHRONIC RISK
IN THE FUTURE. I WORKED IN THE
LABORATORY THAT PROVED INSECT
RESISTANCE TO DDT WEISSE
PELICANS IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES DETAIL ALSO MADE ME AND
FOR TILE. EIGHT PESTICIDE
SURVIVOR I STUDIED PUBLIC
HEALTH PESTICIDES IN FOOD. THE
MILK CAN BE HIGHER REGENERATIVE
FARMS ARE MORE PROFITABLE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T USE THESE
ARTIFICIAL CHEMICAL INPUTS
ORGANIC FARMING IS PROOF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE SCHOOL THANK
YOU WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SIX FIVE. THANK
YOU JERRY MEMBERS ARGUE SHARMA
HERE WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ISSUE SIX
FARMS WHICH WILL BE SHARED YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT AND ENTHUSIASM
FOR ANOTHER YEAR OF FINDING ON
ISSUE SEVEN REGULATORY
ALIGNMENT TO BE OPPOSED BECAUSE
IT MEANS THAT A NUMBER OF
EQUITY AND INCLUSION ISSUES
WITH REGARDS TO THE PUBLIC ONE
CONTRAST. AND ON ISSUE FIVE
TRANSCEND TRANSITION OF THE
PAPER THE THING ABOUT TAX
MANAGEMENT ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
PCRX FIVE THAT CALIFORNIA BEAT
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS CENTER
FIFTY FIFTY CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE
MEETING AND CHEERING THE COUPLE
FIGHT WEALTHY AND WE REFLECT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET TO
DIRECT FUNDS TO FOUR TOP
PRIORITY. BY THE REFUND FOR
COMMUNITY FARM WORKER TO HELP
ARE THREATENED BY HUGE AN
UPDATED COPY BY AIR MONITORING
PROGRAM A PROGRAM TO HELP
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS MANAGE
CASH JAITLEY AND EVEN WITH THE
MONITORING PROGRAM TO AFFECTING
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY- AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
MILKY PROPOSAL AND THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES WE LIKE TO GET DRESSED
CAN BE APPROVED TO GET A
MAJORITY. FIFTY BUCKS. WE
PUBLIC COM FROM LINE NUMBER FOR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. A I
GOOD AFTERNOON. AND NUMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M TO THE ITEMS
AND ONE OF THE TO. ON IF YOU
NINE THE STATE LAW EFFICIENT
AND HELP PRO THAT IS. WE
SUPPORT THIS FORTY DOLLARS FOR
THE PROBE FOR A EFFICIENCY IN.
INCLUDING THE TWENTY FOR EARLY
ACTION. TO REDUCE WATER CAN. ON
ISSUE SEVEN YEAH PAID ALAINA OF
WEBER REQUIREMENTS OUR- THE
PROPOSAL CAN BY FIESTA PROMPT
ON TIME SIX BILLION. ALLOCATION
OF GENERAL DOLLARS AND FINALLY
WE OPPOSE EACH YEAR. ASSESSMENT
PROPOSED H- IF YOU FIVE AGAIN
THE PLANIS FACT AND OF THE
COST OF EVEN THE MOST PAST TASK
MANAGEMENT. INSTEAD WE PUSH WE
WOULD APPRECIATE COLLABORATING
WITH DPR IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
THE DEPARTMENT. HE SAID THANK
YOU. WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX NINE.
YOUR BLOOMIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JODY GRAY
I AM THE CEO OF ELDORADO COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS IN PLACERVILLE WE
ARE COUNTY NONPROFIT I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROBATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE FAIR NETWORK
HOWEVER THIS MONEY TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE NETWORK
OF FAIR. HISTORICALLY
APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE STATE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO ALL PLAYERS REGARDLESS
OF STRUCTURE ALL FIGURES IN THE
NETWORK HAVE BEEN HIT HARD BY
CO BUT IT ALL NEED ASSISTANCE
IF THEY HAVE A CHANCE OF
SURVIVING ARE THERE GROUNDS OF
THE SITE BECAUSE THE TESTING.
PP DISTRIBUTIONS FOR USE AS A
FACTORY IN CENTER FIRE CAMP YES
YES I. CAN AND COOLING CENTERS
DURING EXTREME WEATHER AND WE
ARE THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
PLEASE MAKE SURE ALL OF THE
CAN'T SURVIVE WHEN YOU VOTE ON.
THE MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM NUMBERS. ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. FIVE ONE.
GOOD MORNING BONTA THANK THE
BEGINNING A LOT GANDERBAL
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE STATE EXISTING
COMMITMENT. TO CLEAN UP THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED CONTAMINATED
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
SURROUNDING THE EXCITABILITY.
OF AN ESTIMATED SIXTY EIGHT
HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
REMAINED THE PLANE. REPORT ALSO
SUPPORTS SUFFICIENT FUNDING
UNTIL ALL RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES IN THE AFFECTED
AREAS ARE QUITE. BIG RESIDENTS
HAVE SEPARATE PARTS ALONG AND
IF THERE'S A STATE COMMITMENT
UNTIL ALL THE PROPERTY.
ACCORDING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. AND WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS APPLYING SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE AHEAD. SIX LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I'M
BROWN FIGHTERS WITH THEIR
INCOME BY SEVEN SECTORS IN
VENTURA WE'RE GOING ISSUE FIVE
TRANSITION TO SAFER
SUSTAINABLE- PAST MANAGEMENT AS
THE PEST CONTROL ADVISOR
WORKING FOR BENEFICIAL INSECTS
I KNOW THAT NONE OF THESE TOXIC
MATERIALS ARE NEEDED TO PRODUCE
OUR FOOD. SUPPLY SUGGESTING A
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
MILKING ON MORNING AND DANGER
LEVEL PRODUCT SO IT'S MORE OF A
SIGNIFICANT DISINCENTIVE. IT'S
ARAMBULA TRIVIAL MARKET SIGNAL
THE FUNDS CAN CERTAINLY BE USED
BY DPR TO SUPPORT- THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
PESTICIDE USE AND- IT SHOULD BE
EFFECTIVE- IN ONE YEAR. IT'S
TIME TO DROP THE CHARADE THAT
PESTICIDES ARE USEFUL CHEMICAL
TOOLS AND ADMIT THAT THEY ARE
TOXINS THAT HARM THE GOOD
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
DECREASE OUR ABILITY. TO GROW
FOOD NEXT YEAR THANK YOU. AND
GET MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AND NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE CONTINUE. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND THAT BRINGS US
TO THE CONCLUSION OF OUR
MEETING WE STAND ADJOURNED.